[Musik]
schön dass ihr dabei seid zdf heute live
wir warten hier für euch gemeinsam auf
die pressekonferenz zum bunten länder
treffen die seht ihr auch schon im
bildschirm hinter mir da treffen sich
die ministerpräsidenten präsidentin mit
kanzlerin merkel in sachen corona das
dauert manchmal länger manchmal geht es
schnell dass man auch so eine
pressekonferenz wartet vielleicht habt
ihr ein bisschen zeit mitgebracht macht
euch gemütlich und wir gehen auf jeden
fall dann live wenn da was passiert
haben aber vorher ein bisschen zeit zu
sprechen ich habe mir hier auch im
studio ich stehe hier nicht alleine
felix zimmermann von recht und justiz
eingeladen hat felix schön dass du da
bist wir können nämlich dann auch mit
felix alle fragen klären in juristischer
sache und wenn ihr eben eure fragen
direkt in den stream schreibt oder da
jetzt schon vorab irgendwas wissen wollt
dann meldet euch gerne jederzeit auch
per mail werden blenden euch die adresse
jetzt ein und zumindest ja hoffen wir
dass wir am ende von dieser
pressekonferenz pressekonferenz dann
noch ein bisschen schlauer sind wie es
also weiter geht in sachen corona und
wir können über diese pressekonferenz im
nachhinein und jetzt auch schon vorab
sprechen mit meiner kollegin nicole
diekmann im hauptstadtstudio in berlin
wenn sie dann schon da ist und wir sie
gleich sehen und da ist auch nicole
schon hallo schön dass du da bist hier
bin ich danke dass ich da sein darf sehr
schön nicole wir haben ja noch ein
bisschen zeit wahrscheinlich bis es
losgeht deswegen schon mal gleich am
anfang die frage aber eigentlich ist
schon was durchgesickert weißt du schon
was was wir da vielleicht gleich hören
ja genau es sich tatsächlich wie
eigentlich immer bei diesen
ministerpräsidenten konferenzen etwas
durch und zwar
steht unter anderem der hospitalisierung
index im zentrum der debatten das hatte
sich gestern schon angedeutet ich
erkläre mal kurz was das ist der
hospitalisierung index bedeutet wie
viele menschen auf 100000 einwohner
hochgerechnet mit corona ins krankenhaus
kommen da hatte angela merkel im moment
ja noch geschäftsführende kanzlerin
gestern schon einen pflock vor dieser
heutigen sitzung eingeschlagen sie war
zu gast zugeschaltet beim städte und
gemeindebund und sagte dort sie möchte
sie wünscht sich dass an diesen index
konsequenzen gebunden sind also wenn man
so will soll der hospitalisierung index
der die neue instanz werden es gibt an
solchen tagen wie heute im vorfeld ja
immer viele papiere das sind die
sogenannten beschlussvorlagen es gab
gestern schon eine da fand sich eine
eckige klammer zum thema
hospitalisierung cent dexter hatte man
also noch kein wert festgelegt ab dem
dann strengere maßnahmen gelten könnten
dann gab es im lauf des heutigen tages
ein neues papier da fand sich die zahl
sechs das bedeutet ab sechs menschen in
einem bundesland hochgerechnet auf
hunderttausend einwohner die eben ins
krankenhaus müssen mit corona soll
entweder zwei gelten flächendeckend oder
sogar zweig plus das heißt also auch
getestete und genesene müssen dann
aktuelle tests verweisen um an
bestimmten veranstaltungen teilnehmen zu
dürfen um bestimmte räumlichkeiten wie
zum beispiel restaurants oder hotels
betreten zu dürfen beziehungsweise da
übernachten zu dürfen jetzt sickern
allmählich die ersten zahlen durch und
das sind 3 und 6 das sollen also die
stufen seien ab 3 ihre spezialisierung
sin 63 soll flächendeckend in einem
bundesland zwar gelten und ab dem
hospitalisierung index 6 soll zweig plus
gelten nun ringt man dem vernehmen nach
noch darum was bei 9 also wenn noch mehr
menschen ins krankenhaus müssen was dann
passieren soll und du hast angesprochen
es sind klang spannend es gab jetzt im
vorfeld schon zwei papiere 1 gestern 1
heute was waren denn dann noch für
unterschiedlichkeiten es ist sehr
interessant dass ich das jetzt schon im
vorfeld zwei verschiedenen papiere gibt
oder zumindest zwei leicht
unterschiedliche papiere ja das ist
normal das ist immer ganz interessant
für uns die wir die papiere dann
üblichen tschuldigung aus
unterschiedlichen quellen bekommen zu
sehen wie verlaufen da eigentlich die
diskussions linien und was sind wirklich
anscheinend schwierige punkte wo man
sich nicht so schnell einigen kann und
ich hab's ja gerade erwähnt dass eine
war eben der hospitalisierung index ein
tolles wort und an einen anderen punkt
hat man gesehen da wurde jetzt auch im
vorfeld schon sozusagen entschärft und
da ging es darum
was man sich hier eigentlich vornimmt
was die sogenannten booster impfung
angeht also die auffrischungsimpfungen
da statt im ersten entwurf standen da
noch eckige klammern die wand vorgesehen
für eine zahl nämlich eine zielmarke wie
viele dieser booster impfungen
auffrischungsimpfungen man bis zum ende
des jahres noch schaffen will diese
eckigen klammern sind jetzt im neuen
papier weg was noch nichts bedeutet die
können auch wieder kommen bzw wenn wir
gleich die pkw an die pressekonferenz
kann es sein dass man sich da doch noch
mal ein ehrgeiziges ziel gesetzt hat
aber anscheinend ist man erst mal von
gestern auf heute
da hingelangt zu sagen wir schreiben da
man lieber keine zahl rein denn das
bedeutete beinhaltet ja auch immer die
gefahr das risiko diese zahl zu
verfehlen das heißt also offensichtlich
zu scheitern in den bemühungen
über genau diese booster impfungen was
da vielleicht sinn macht oder auch nicht
können wir später auch noch sprechen mit
professor christine falk sie ist die
präsidentin der deutschen gesellschaft
für immunologie und nicole an dieser
stelle wir sehen uns natürlich wieder
erst mal vielen dank an dich und wir es
passiert was in sachen corona also es
ist jetzt zum einen heute also die
pressekonferenz auf die wir warten und
heute ist aber noch was passiert und
zwar hat der bundestag schon mal den
änderungen der zukünftigen
voraussichtlich ampel koalition
zugestimmt am infektionsschutzgesetz
hatten die änderung vorgenommen also
bundestag hat schon ja gesagt auch wenn
union und fdp dagegen waren aber in der
minderheit und morgen muss darüber aber
auch noch der bundesrat entscheiden das
ist also noch nicht ganz sicher ob das
durchgeht die cdu dass es fraglich ob
die dazu stimmt wir haben jetzt aber
auch mal einen kleinen beitrag dazu noch
was es da heute genau passiert im
bundestag worüber wurde gesprochen von
heike slansky
es wird einen schlagabtausch zwischen
union und kommen der ampel regierung im
neuen gesetzentwurf sei alles drin nur
keine flächendeckenden lockt downs mehr
sagt die
spd-länder haben mit dem vorgelegten
gesetzentwurf mehr möglichkeiten des
efsf anders als bei der aktuell noch
gültigen rechtslage
233 g + kontakt beschränkungen im
öffentlichen und privaten bereich
personen obergrenzen doch die union
fordert erneut die verlängerung der
epidemischen lage von nationaler
tragweite
wir haben einen guten rechtsrahmen den
schlagen sie uns und dem land aus der
hand und sie ersetzen ihn durch etwas
was weniger wert weniger wertvoll ist
dem kann ich zustimmen objektiv falsch
nennt das die fdp das neue gesetz sei
ein scharfes schwert in der pandemie
bekämpfung wir haben effektive maßnahme
um gegner zu bekämpfen behaupten sie
nicht das gegenteil das ist
wahrheitswidrig meine damen und die
grünen kritisieren was alles nicht getan
wurde von der noch amtierenden regierung
seit wie vielen wochen und monaten
hatten eigentlich dass corinna kabinett
nicht getagt ich könnte fragen
[Applaus]
wo ist eigentlich der große plan zum
boost an dem man spätestens zu beginn
des septembers hätte besprechen müssen
der bundestag nimmt den entwurf mit den
stimmen der ampel fraktionen an doch die
union droht mit blockade morgen im
bundesrat deshalb bleibt offen ob das
gesetz kommende woche wirklich in kraft
treten kann
beitrag von christiane hübscher da hatte
ich zuvor eine falsche info und hier
gibts jetzt fragen die wir stellen
können an felix zimmermann von recht und
justiz felix wie unterscheidet sich denn
jetzt dieses neue gesetz von der
bisherigen rechtslage es gibt einerseits
mehr und auf der anderen seite gibt es
weniger ja das meer ist das jetzt eben
neue maßnahmen möglich sind auf den weg
gebracht werden das wäre zum beispiel
die 3g regelung im öffentlichen
nahverkehr
das heißt da müssen den kontrollen
stattfinden damit nicht ungeimpfte und
personen in den in den öffentlichen
nahverkehr gehen die keinen test
nachweis haben dann wird's also
kontrollaufwand geben dann geht die
träge 3g am arbeitsplatz verpflichtend
das ist auch noch eine verschärfung auch
mit neuen kontrollen verbunden dann wird
home office als verpflichtung ein gesetz
das bedeutet nur wenn durch zwingende
gründe
dafür sprechen dass der arbeitnehmer in
den betrieb kommen muss muss er auch
kommen ansonsten ist will ich eine
weitgehende home office pflicht und die
testpflicht werden auch ausgewertet was
die altenheimer und pflegeeinrichtungen
anbetrifft hier gibt auch eine
testfläche und das ist das was an mehr
gibt aber auf der anderen seite gibt es
eben weniger wenn es jetzt um die
freiheitsbeschränkung mit dort wurde
jetzt zum beispiel gesagt es darf keine
allgemeinen ausgangs beschränkung mehr
geben was wir in der vergangenheit
hatten und auch was versammlungen angeht
oder gottesdienste soll es eben keine
weiteren beschränkungen will wobei die
länder die können auch weiterhin
tatsächlich schon kontakt beschränkungen
das können sie anordnen oder genau das
war ja so dass der erste and
gesetzentwurf beinhaltet das ist auch
keine kontakt beschränkung mehr geben
darf da hat jetzt aber die zukünftige
oder potenziell zukünftigen blick
koalition angesichts der doch dramatisch
werden dann lage reagiert und hat gesagt
wie gut dieses mittel das geben wir
jetzt doch wieder den ländern als
möglichkeit und sie müssen ist ja nicht
nutzen die länder aber als möglichkeit
weil das ist nun mal das ist wo
möglicherweise am meisten die das virus
sich überträgt das geben wir wobei am
anfang die fdp eigentlich gesagt hatte
wir halten das eigentlich nur für
ungeimpfte für verhältnismäßig und nicht
was geimpfte angeht also da könnte es
dann auch wieder gerichtlichen streit
geben denn die klausel wie sie jetzt
dort steht ist wirklich offen dass sie
auch kontakt beschränkung für geimpfte
personen vorsieht und das sehen einige
rechtswissenschaftler sehr kritisch weil
die flamme nun wirklich alles getan den
solidarischen beitrag geleistet warum
sollte es dann dort weiter kontakt
beschränkungen geben ist die eine seite
die andere seite ist naja weil eben auch
von geimpften eine sehr reduzierte aber
immerhin auch infektionsgefahr rausgeht
und man das im pauschal regeln müsse zum
beispiel weil auch sonst kontrollen viel
schwieriger möglich sind weil auf dem
straßenbild wer erkennt dort erst mal
als polizist ob es sich um personen
handelt die geimpften nicht geimpfter
deswegen so eine pauschale regelung ist
immer einfacher zur kontrolle aber das
ist quasi aus der perspektive des
der regierenden und dass polizisten aber
was und wenn es um die
verhältnismäßigkeit geht dann kommt
eigentlich auch für die perspektive auch
der bürger innen an und dauert es
natürlich eine maßnahme gegen geimpfte
schwerwiegend aber so weit sind wir ja
auch nicht ist es ja nur die möglichkeit
der kontakt beschränkung wieder jetzt
geschaffen worden
fakt ist dass die zahlen also im moment
ja wirklich stark steigen der korona
neuinfizierten also deshalb kommt er
jetzt auch natürlich ein bisschen
bewegung in die sache ich frage mal kurz
in die regie ob wir denn in dem ich den
präsidenten des robert-koch-instituts
lothar wieler ob wir da schon den o-ton
vorliegen haben gestern der hat sich
nämlich sehr eindringlich jetzt auch
noch mal geäußert anbetracht dieser
zahlen und deswegen wir können jetzt
tatsächlich in diesem ton mal reinhören
hatte ich gehofft er kommt gleich
sie laufen momentan in eine ernste
notlage wir werden wirklich ein sehr
schlimmes weihnachtsfest haben wenn wir
jetzt nicht gegensteuern
das ist eine klare sprache aber ich kann
nach 21 monaten ist auch schlichtweg
nicht mehr ertragen das ist nicht
vielleicht erkannt wird was ich unter
anderem sagen wie auch viele andere
kollegen und goalie
brechen mit professor christine fei
präsidentin der deutschen gesellschaft
für immunologie schönen guten abend frau
ja schon genannt frau professor falk
haben gerade luther wieder den lkw
präsident gehört er fühlt sich nicht
gehört auch in seinem appell und das
scheinbar schon lange nicht geht es
ihnen und kolleginnen und kollegen da
genauso
er hat in der tat darauf hingewiesen
dass ja schon im juli ein papier des
robert koch instituts mit möglichen
szenarien je nachdem wie viele menschen
der gesamtbevölkerung geimpft sind
veröffentlicht wurde und da sieht man
ganz klar dass wir unter dieser
sinnvollen linie von 75% menschen die
schon geimpft sind geblieben sind und
dieses szenario sah in der tat vor dass
die zahlen dann sehr stark ansteigen
genau das ist passiert und deswegen hat
er sehr zu recht darauf hingewiesen dass
da schon immer diskutiert wurde dass
dieses szenario möglich ist
und dass er natürlich wie viele von uns
dieses szenario gerne vermeiden möchte
oder hätte wollen und jetzt stehen wir
trotzdem vor den hohen zahlen daher kann
ich dem nur zustimmen dass das ein
eindringlicher appell war weil es ist
unbedingt handlungsbedarf jetzt
erforderlich wir werden ja sehen wie das
jetzt kommuniziert wird und was
sozusagen geschlossen wurde aber dass
wir jetzt unbedingt was tun müssen ist
vollkommen klar insofern bei dieser
appell sehr sehr gut nachvollziehbar
jetzt könnten natürlich verschiedene
maßnahmen kommen verschiedene es könnte
passieren wir hatten es am anfang von
nicole diekmann aus dem hauptstadtstudio
schon gehört auch booster impfungen
könnten ein teil jetzt der diskussion
seien aber vielleicht hält man sich da
wohl auch zurück das war jetzt so
nicoles lesart vielleicht hält man sich
auch zurück mit der großen
versprechungen was man da schaffen will
wie wichtig sind denn booster impfung
jetzt aktuell
booster impfungen sind auf jeden fall
sehr wichtig vor allem auch für die
älteren menschen und die menschen deren
immunsystem nicht ganz so gut
funktioniert wie bei normal personen zb
aber die ständige impfkommission wird
sich auch dazu äußern dass man nicht
mehr nur über diese altersgrenze spricht
sondern es allen menschen die zweimal
geimpft sind ungefähr nach sechs monaten
nach der zweiten impfung an rät sich
eine auffrischimpfung oder vielleicht
könnte man sagen auch eine dritte
impfung didier sozusagen den vorgang
noch mal komplett macht sich abzuholen
ganz einfach deshalb weil wir sehen dass
den impfstatus den wir erreicht haben
der schützt nicht ausreichend davor dass
wir so viel beta variante jetzt
zirkulieren haben also es ein aspekt
ganz wichtig dass die menschen eine
dritte impfung bekommen und zwar nach
einer zeit staffelung aber auch noch mal
die priorisierung im blick und das
zweite ist noch mindestens genauso
wichtig dass wir die erstimpfungen noch
erhöhen denn wir sind eben unter dieser
magischen marke sozusagen von 75 prozent
überhaupt erst den bereich erlauben
würde dass wir eine weitere virus
ausbreitung
etwas bremsen können das heißt wir
brauchen deutlich mehr als 75 prozent
der gesamtbevölkerung und die zwei dinge
ging es eng zusammen und wir brauchen in
der tat beides auffrischimpfungen und
eine erhöhte frequenz und erhöhte zahl
der erst im kommen auch zum thema impfen
hatte sich der lka-präsident gestern
noch mal geäußert da wollen wir auch
kurz reinhören
es muss jetzt schluss sein dass
irgendwer
irgendwelchen anderen berufsgruppen
aufgrund von irgendwelchen umständen
nicht gestattet zu impfen wir sind in
einer notlage und in einer notlage muss
man bestimmte dinge großzügig gestalten
darum bin ich hier ganz klar dafür dass
unter anderem apotheker impfen sollen
wir brauchen jeden und jede um jetzt zu
impfen
jetzt hab ich im studio zumindest nur
ein standbild das lka präsidentin
gesehen aber gehört habe ich ihnen also
er sagte wir brauchen jeden und jeder um
jetzt zu impfen würden sie dem zustimmen
da also so dass er mann mit den
verschiedenen verbänden im spricht und
wird wie die rückmeldungen sind ist es
natürlich so dass die hausärztinnen und
hausärzte betriebsärzte praxen etc
natürlich bemüht sind aber dass wenn wir
jetzt wirklich da passiert vorgehen
wollen das möglicherweise nicht
ausreicht wir wollen aus verschiedenen
regionen das selbst ältere menschen die
jetzt versuchen sich eine
auffrischimpfung zu organisieren dann
ins nächste jahr sozusagen mit einem
termin vertröstet werden das ist viel zu
lange also man kann sehr gut
nachvollziehen dass möglicherweise
regional unterschiedlich aber dennoch es
sehr notwendig sein wird neue formate
für das impfen mit dazu zu nehmen und
vor allem die mobilen angebote zu
erhöhen das land niedersachsen macht das
schon das sind wirklich dinge die den
menschen es einfach machen sollen sich
die auffrischimpfung zu organisieren
aber auch die erstimpfung dann nochmal
zu ermöglichen und da glaube ich ist es
wirklich sehr sehr gut wenn man den
rechtlichen rahmen betrachtet das ist
nicht meine expertise aber wenn man
möglich macht was irgendwie funktioniert
und sicher ist für die menschen die sich
impfen lassen kann man das in der tat
nur unterstützen wenn die apotheken das
dürfen und das organisiert werden kann
warum nicht wir brauchen tatsächlich
eine ganz starke proaktive impfaktion
jetzt
falk für den moment für diesen
rechtlichen rahmen haben wir ja jemand
im studio da können wir direkt
weitermachen mit felix zimmermann wir
hören uns später wieder frau professor
felix frau professor falk gerade
angesprochen also dass da
vielleicht auch ein rechtlicher rahmen
geschaffen werden könnte aber dauert so
was vielleicht auch braucht das dann am
ende viel zeit zeit die wir nicht haben
uns konzentrieren das ja ein
beispielloses versagen was diese booster
impfung angeht also morgens nur auf
israel gucken da sagen die daten ganz
klar dass so sollen ab dem fünften monat
spätestens die impfung erfolgt nachlässt
und wir sind jetzt mittendrin die zahlen
steigen und steigen das hätte man auch
mal vorher bedenken können dass man
diese booster impfung braucht da fragt
man sich wirklich wie kann es sein dass
es jetzt in diesem zeitpunkt erst
geschieht wo die zahlen schon so hoch
sind und die auch teilweise viel viel
weniger als ungeimpfte aber eben auch
geimpfte erkranken und den rechtlichen
rahmen da gibt es eben verwirrung ganz
faktische art bei den ärzten denn es ist
so dass eben teilweise die normen diese
aktuell gibt so interpretiert wird das
erst ab sechs monaten nach der impfung
wirklich eine booster impfung möglich
ist das ist wohl rechtlich falsch aber
dieser irrtum kursiert und da gibt es
viele ärzte die bei dieser ungeklärten
rechtslage sagen ich möchte vielleicht
auch das risiko jetzt nicht eingehen
ganz konkret sagen ja diese haftung
möchte ich jetzt nicht übernehmen wenn
ich sicher ist dass hier überhaupt die
booster impfung machen darf also hier
hat sozusagen die politik klar versagt
denn der rechtliche rahmen wurde and
erstens unklar formuliert und zweitens
nicht zutreffend kommuniziert so dass
die booster impfung hier schnell
vonstatten gehen könnte
alles klar danke für den moment wir
schauen mal ganz kurz hinter mir sehe
ich doch schon ich wollte mal
nachschauen ob sie schon was tut weil
eigentlich hieß es mal 17 auf 15 soll es
losgehen na ja selbst nur 20 und immer
noch nichts ich hab's ja am anfang fast
befürchtet wir sind ja eine weile
zusammen aber ist ja auch spannend wir
haben uns viele gäste eingeladen um zu
sprechen und vielleicht schalten wir
auch noch mal nach berlin wenn nicole
diekmann dann noch für uns zur verfügung
steht was ich sehr hoffe und fragen bei
nicole noch mal nach ob sie schon
näheres weiß da natürlich wunderbar da
bist du noch gott sei dank ob du schon
näheres weiß wenn das jetzt schon wieder
so ein bisschen später erst losgeht sind
das zeichen dafür dass man eben bei
einzelnen punkten echt noch mal genauer
was klären muss ja also er ich gehe hier
nicht weg keine sorge ich bleib hier
einfach sitzen es gab tatsächlich gerade
eben vor fünf minuten die info aus dem
kanzleramt es könnte sich jetzt noch mal
um 10 15 minuten
verlängern also nach hinten schieben das
heißt von jetzt an bis zehn minuten aber
das ist immer nicht in stein gemeißelt
genau das ist natürlich ein zeichen
dafür dass es noch redebedarf gibt dass
man sich noch nicht in allen punkten
einig ist wenn man das überhaupt heute
wird
was klar ist ist dass der öffentliche
druck hoch ist dass man erstens heute
tatsächlich geschlossen auftritt auch
wenn die halbwertszeit nach solchen
beschlüssen von ministerpräsidenten
konferenzen ja das wissen wir aus der
vergangenheit immer hatten eher so
mittel ist das wären dann doch wieder
einzelne aus und es gibt dann doch
wieder den berühmten flickenteppich
zweitens ist aber auch der druck hoch
die erwartungshaltung der öffentlichkeit
dass man beschlüsse präsentiert denn wir
haben in den letzten wochen seit der
bundestagswahl beziehungsweise seitdem
die zahlen wieder so explodieren vier
parteien gerade gesehen wir haben jetzt
auf der einen seite eine bundesregierung
die noch geschäftsführend im amt ist und
wir haben auf der anderen seite eine
ampel die ja höchstwahrscheinlich in amt
in ihre ämter in amt und würden kommen
wird es aber eben noch nicht ist und da
vermuten einige hinter vielen
scharmützeln hinter diskussionen vor
allem parteipolitik einer partei vor
allem der union die demnächst in der
opposition sitzen wird und eben auf der
anderen seite denjenigen die sich jetzt
probieren wollen weil sie eben die ämter
die macht übernehmen werden dh
mann erwartet jetzt dass das ein ende
hat und dass man tatsächlich
pragmatische lösungen schnell
präsentiert weil das virus sagte angela
merkel gestern die ist aber natürlich
auch teil des ganzen dem virus ist es
egal ob es schon eine fest installierte
regierung gibt eine vereidigte regierung
oder im moment eine in anführungszeichen
nur geschäftsführender ich glaube das
ist ja auch etwas was viele menschen
derzeit auch ein bisschen verwirrt also
wir haben zum einen noch nicht eine fest
stehende ampel koalition auch wenn es
natürlich danach aussieht wir haben eine
geschäftsführende regierung aber von der
kam ja bislang nicht so viel jetzt im
bezug auf die un gehen wir jetzt aktuell
gerade um mit corona erwartest du da
jetzt wirklich dass da etwas anders ist
nach heute
naja fragst du mich als journalistin
oder fragst du mich als bürgerin als
naja ich erwarte dass eigentlich als
beides was man muss ja auch sagen dass
auch vom höchst wahrscheinlich demnächst
amtierenden kanzlers relativ wenig kam
in dieser frage und die zeit rennt wir
heute den 18 das heißt in einer woche am
nämlich läuft ja die lage die
epidemische lage nationaler tragweite
aus es gab heute ja im bundestag die
abstimmung über das gesetzespaket der
kommenden ampel höchstwahrscheinlich
kommenden ampel über die änderung des
infektionsschutzgesetzes
weil die epidemische lage eben ausläuft
und weil die ampel die auch auslaufen
lassen will die union die cdu hat er
heute gegen gestimmt die union hat er
heute gegen bestimmt ist dagegen aber
was auch immer es muss jetzt was
passieren dass darüber sind sich alle
einig ja es muss was passieren auch
gerade natürlich im bereich impfen und
gibt es auch verschiedenste impfstoffe
und verschiedene gedanken die man jetzt
natürlich umgehen soll booster impfungen
oder auch eben jetzt wie kriegt man mehr
menschen dazu sich impfen zu lassen wir
haben dazu einen beitrag zu diesem
ganzen hochkomplexen thema von christian
von rechenberg
zwei impfungen das war's schuldigkeit
getan ab in die freiheit
dachten wir dann kam delta ansteckender
robuster ideal angepasst an eine noch
nicht ausreichend geschützte bevölkerung
delta hat die lage verändert
auch für vollständig geimpft und genesen
man muss auch noch mal ganz klar sagen
diesen winter müssen auch die geimpften
noch einmal etwas disziplin halten das
heißt auch als geimpfte muss man
realisieren dass man ansteckend sein
kann unbemerkt neue studien aus england
lassen aufhorchen sie zeigen dass
geimpfte mit impf durchbrüchen unter
umständen eine ähnlich hohe viruslast
haben können wie ungeimpfte allerdings
im vergleich in einem viel kürzeren
zeitraum heißt die impfung macht eine
weitergabe des virus schwierige aber
eben nicht unmöglich
wie stark dieser schutz vor der
weitergabe ist hängt aber auch davon ab
wie lange meine zweite impfung her ist
das heißt er war am anfang mal relativ
gut und da hat man ein 80 oder 90
prozentigen schutz vor der weitergabe
gehabt jetzt gibt es studien die sagen
der schutz ist nur noch 60 prozent
andere studien die sagen ist es gerade
mal so gut 30 prozent das heißt man gibt
es immer noch weniger weiter als ein
nicht geimpfter aber der unterschied
nimmt immer weiter ab und dass abhängig
von alter begleiterkrankung oder dem
impfstoff nach relativ kurzer zeit das
was ist die studien aufzeigen dass circa
drei monate nach vollem visierung
diese schutzwirkung vor übertragung bei
astrazeneca im prinzip nicht mehr
vorhanden ist und bei und sechs schritt
was er untergeht und das ist glaube ich
dass sie letztlich auch sehr sehr
wesentliche argumente für die
auffrischungsimpfung die ergebnisse
unterstreichen die wichtigkeit dieser
auffrischungsimpfung für genesene und
geimpfte bringen ein zeitfenster ins
spiel offen inwieweit dieses künftig ein
rolle spielt zudem zeigen die studien
auch wie zentral zweig plus werden
könnte also die pflicht für geimpfte und
genesene sich zusätzlich zu testen maske
zu tragen abstand zu halten auch wenn es
nervt
ich glaube wir müssen versuchen
jede
maßnahme die in irgendeiner form
darstellt und realisierbar ist was wir
die zum jetzigen zeitpunkt auch nützen
weil die spitäler fühlen sich und das
ist absehbar dass die demnächst voll
sein werden allerdings einige experten
mahnen dass ein flächendeckendes testen
für alle menschen kaum realisierbar ist
tests im privaten und im umfeld
verletzlicher gruppen ja ansonsten solle
die energie in eine strategie fließen
nicht in viele
dass wir die impflücken schließen und
das wusste wird das ist das einzige was
wirklich nachhaltig wird alles andere
sind überbrückungsmaßnahmen wir sind
jetzt aus der not geboren weil wenn ich
früher angefangen haben damit die
fallzahlen wirklich wieder runtergehen
das wissen aus der erfahrung aus israel
würde es zum beispiel helfen 50 prozent
der menschen zu fuß kann sich mit seiner
booster impfung gerade bei den jüngeren
dann auch von den instanzen hier aus
einer welle raus fazit die impfung
schützt und ist elementar im kampf gegen
korona und doch sollten sich geimpfte
und genieße nicht zurücklehnen sondern
ihren impfschutz soweit nötig und
empfohlen auffrischen und bis dahin
aufpassen auf sich und die menschen um
sie herum
wir alle müssen vorsichtig sein
aufpassen ob geimpft oder nicht frau
professor falk also wir haben gerade
gehört das natürlich auch testen wichtig
ist und wichtig bleibt immer schon
wichtig war aber wenn es jetzt da so ein
bisschen auch eine debatte gibt wie
wichtig ist ein booster impfung wie
wichtig ist impfen versus das testen wie
ist ihre einschätzung also wie wichtig
ist dass das eine test strategie bleibt
wir haben gesehen dass für die der
anspruch der impfung war ja bisher vor
allem die menschen zu schützen auch vor
schweren verläufen dass sie ins
krankenhaus kommen das werden wir
nachher noch sehen wie wichtig diese
parameter ist da wir jetzt aber sehr
hohe infektionszahlen haben ist unser
anspruch gegen oder anspruch an die
impfung gestiegen denn jetzt müssen wir
auch damit umgehen dass wir mit der
impfung verhindern müssen dass weitere
infektionen passieren diese sogenannte
transmission also die weitergabe des
virus von menschen zu anderen und da wir
jetzt diesen höheren anspruch haben es
sozusagen die notwendigkeit dass die
menschen optimal geschützt sind so gut
ist irgend geht mit hohen antikörpern
und wohnen t-zellen ganz besonders
wichtig und da kommt jetzt die tests
strategie dazu wir wissen das wussten
wir auch schon vorher dass menschen die
zweimal geimpft sind nicht schwer
erkranken aber das risiko dass sie doch
sich anstecken und weitergeben ist halt
nicht nur wenn wir wenig virus
zirkulieren haben dann ist es nicht
relevant aber jetzt mit diesen hohen
zahlen mit heute
65.000 neuinfektionen gemeldet für
gestern da bleibt mir persönlich
wirklich einen stockt mir der atem haben
wir so viel die russin der gesellschaft
dass wir auch die geimpften in diesen
schutz vor weitergabe des virus mit
hinein nehmen müssen und jetzt müssen
wir dann wirklich auch sehen dass nicht
jeder mensch der zweimal geimpft ist
quasi die optimale wirkung hat so dass
er gar nicht mehr infiziert und virus
weitergeben kann und weil wir jetzt
sicherstellen müssen dass auch dieser
vielleicht kleine aber trotzdem anteil
der geimpften an dieser transmission
möglichst verhindert wird ist eine
zusätzliche tests strategie sinnvoll
deswegen haben wir ja die diskussion
zweig würde heißen genesen und geimpft
und 2g plus würde bedeuten dass man in
bestimmten situationen unter bestimmten
rahmenbedingungen wie infektionszahlen
et cetera sogar die geimpften noch mal
testen muss um wirklich auch möglichst
alle leute raus zu fischen die in der
nase im rachen raum virus haben und
weitergeben können und das kann man
unter anderem mit gut durchgeführten
antigen schnelltests machen man kann die
pcr tests noch mal forcieren das ist
sozusagen eine zusätzliche
schutzmaßnahmen nicht weil die impfungen
nicht wirkt sondern einfach weil wir
jetzt jede maßnahme dazu nehmen müssen
in diesem katalog der uns hätte uns
hilft die weitergabe des virus zu
unterdrücken wie die impfungen wie frau
prise man das ganz richtig gesagt hat
die sind das allerwichtigste im
instrument das wir haben auffrischen und
erstimpfungen aber zusätzlich müssen wir
wirklich in betracht ziehen möglichst
alle herauszufischen die infektiös sein
könnten also auch die menschen die schon
geimpft wurden
es gibt viele fragen sie im stream frau
professor falk ich möchte nur ganz kurz
noch mal einen blick auf die
pressekonferenz auf den langen tisch
werfen und da mal nachschauen ob schon
was zu sehen ist also ob sich schon was
tut wenn es dann noch ruhig ist und
danach sieht es ja aus dann können wir
auch gerne noch jetzt endlich mal fragen
aus dem stream an frau professor falk
aufnehmen und sobald es losgeht würden
wir aber natürlich unterbrechen und dann
live zur pressekonferenz schalten aber
frau professor falk wir haben also jetzt
für den moment zeit vielleicht ich weiß
sie haben es jetzt auch schon mehrfach
gesagt aber es kommt immer wieder
deswegen finde ich es wichtig dass wird
es nochmal aufgreifen lucia bei youtube
fragt warum schützt die impfung die
geimpften denn nicht wäre nicht eine
impfung medikament sinnvoll welches
tatsächlich auch wirkt dann hätten wir
das problem jetzt nicht also dann
müssten sie vielleicht noch mal ganz
deutlich machen wie gut die im wie gut
geimpfte menschen durch die impfung
geschützt sind und wo es vielleicht
nicht reicht
das ist mir eine ganz wichtige
information natürlich wirkt die impfung
alle menschen die zweimal geimpft wurden
zeigen eine immunreaktion mit
antikörperbildung und tcl bildung so das
ja
sehr gut messen können und auch davon
ausgehen können dass alle menschen mit
einem gesunden immunsystem sehr gut auf
diese sehr gute impfung reagieren und
anfangs in den ersten drei vier fünf
monaten das ist auch weltweit publiziert
auch in deutschland auch wir messen das
ist dieser impfschutz sehr gut wenn man
die im hirn reaktivität ist also zum
beispiel essen kann dann wissen wir wie
gut die impfung wirkt die frage wie die
menschen dann geschützt sind vor
infektionen ist eine andere art das zu
bewerten das sind die studien die auch
gerade im beitrag von herrn werkteile
erwähnt wurden da wird dann geguckt wenn
man länger als sechs monate nach der
zweiten impfung die menschen beobachtet
und sich dann fragt wer steckt sich denn
an dann ist es so dass man sieht und das
ist etwas was die immunologisch immer
schon wussten und es ist immer so dass
das immunsystem die antikörper nicht auf
diesen höchsten niveau hält weil es sehr
ökonomisch arbeitet dann gehen die
antikörper ganz natürlicher weise im
blut etwas runter das ist überhaupt
nichts dramatisches das ist ein ganz
normaler vorgang nur wenn wir jetzt so
hohe infektionszahlen haben dann ist es
wie bei menschen deren da ich nicht die
oberste
würde erreicht hat sondern der dadurch
ist ein bisschen niedriger und das ist
finde ich unbedingt schwierig wenn wir
ganz wenig infektionen haben aber jetzt
haben wir sozusagen einen höheren
anspruch an den da ich wir müssen jetzt
für möglichst viele menschen die höchste
deichhöhe erreichen die wir haben können
heißt möglichst viele antikörper und
immun reaktivität damit diese menschen
sich nicht anstecken also es ist wichtig
zu betonen wie gut die impfreaktion
funktioniert die impfungen funktionieren
bei dieser welle die jetzt an rollt ist
sozusagen bei manchen menschen der da
ich nicht ganz hoch genug und die
kriegen der nasse füße das heißt sie
können sich noch anstecken die
erkrankten nicht schwer aber sie können
es vielleicht weitergeben in einem
kurzen zeitraum also ist unsere aufgabe
die wir jetzt haben und die kommt durch
die hohen infektionszahlen den deich
möglichst für alle menschen möglichst
hoch anzusetzen damit auch die welle
sozusagen dafür nicht mehr ausreicht um
die leute zu infizieren damit die leute
keine nassen füße bekommen und dieses
bild kann man vielleicht benutzen um zu
verstehen was wir jetzt den deich mit
der auffrischimpfung nochmal für alle
erhöhen dann sind die menschen geschützt
umso mehr vor ansteckung und weitergabe
sowieso dann davor schwer zu erkranken
und zusätzlich brauchen wir unbedingt
noch die impf lücke die frau prise mann
angesprochen hat wir haben immer noch
viel zu viele menschen die nicht geimpft
sind und die sollen sich bitte sozusagen
dessen bewusstsein wie wichtig ihre
rolle ist in der pandemie bekämpfung
weil wir mehr erst geimpfte brauchen
damit wir diese lücke schließen können
dann doch immer wieder auch im
durchbrüche auch zu den impf
durchbrüchen gibt es eine frage im
stream da möchte eine userin ein user
mit einem wahnsinnig komplizierten namen
so was ähnliches wie lp skiwachs zwei
wenn ich das richtig ausgesprochen habe
fragt sich warum sagt man immer im
durchbruch stadt mutation
das kann man sehr gut erklären weil eine
mutation ist was ganz anderes die
mutation würde bedeuten das virus hat
sich verändert wir haben jetzt die delta
variante die ist durch mutationen
entstanden und was wahrscheinlich die
zuschauerin meint ist dass wir die delta
variante in deutschland haben wir quasi
über 99 prozent der menschen die sich
anstecken stecken sich mit der data
variante an und die ist ja ein hat ein
schönen gefaltetes stachel protein zwei
proteinen wie dieses virus eben hat
dieses krönchen da oben drauf und diese
struktur ist ein bisschen anders als die
struktur gegen die wir gekämpft werden
weil wir werden ja mit der wildtyp
sequenz mit den m rna oder vector
stoffen geimpft und es gibt menschen da
gehöre ich auch dazu die haben zwar sehr
schöne antikörper gebildet aber
ausgerechnet dieses stückchen das
wichtig ist für das stachel protein der
delta variante dagegen hat man nicht
ganz so viele antikörper deswegen sind
nicht alle menschen gleichermaßen
geschützt und die menschen die nicht
ganz so viele antikörper haben gegen
diese staffel protein sind kandidaten
und kandidatinnen für impft durchbrüche
das heißt das virus kann die lücke
nutzen durch die antikörper front wie
beim fußball durch die abwehr sich noch
durchzumogeln und zellen im nasen rachen
raum zu infizieren also der impf
durchbruch ist das individuelle
aufgestellt sein gegen einen
virusattacke sozusagen da sind manche
mit ihrer abwehr super aufgestellt
andere so wie ich nicht ganz so toll und
dann kann das virus doch noch infizieren
es sind also zwei getrennte dinge die an
zu etwas miteinander zu tun aber wer
sich ansteckt als geimpfte person eben
noch eine andere qualität von
antikörpern und deswegen kann es eben
menschen geben die sich anstecken und um
das zu verhindern
es ist total sinnvoll zu sagen wir
brauchen die dritte impfung die
komplettiert sozusagen die mauer die
abwehrfront die wir da aufbauen möchten
damit die menschen sich nicht infizieren
braucht frau professor volk wir haben
noch mehr möglichkeiten später mit ihr
zu sprechen aber jetzt erst mal wollte
ich noch jeden kommentar von euch auch
im stream aufgreifen bella sp bei
facebook schreibt überall zweig plus und
impfpflicht felix mit so einer
impfpflicht das ist vielleicht ja gar
nicht so einfach also das was wella sp
sich wünscht das ist wahrscheinlich
rechtlich nichts was so einfach
überhaupt gehen würde ja da muss man
quasi abwägen die politik hat hier sehr
früh die impfpflicht ausgeschlossen also
eine wirkliche impfpflicht jeder muss
sich impfen und da stellt sich dann aber
irgendwann mal die frage der
verhältnismäßigkeit ob denn die anderen
maßnahmen zum beispiel das jetzt
geimpfte
weiter zweig plus sich testen lassen
müssen und und vielleicht irgendwann
dann auch wieder kontakt beschränkung
für geimpfte
notfalls vielleicht dann doch irgendwann
noch mal eine ausgangs beschränkung für
geimpfte auch wenn die akte ja nicht
vorgesehen ist das sind ja lauter
maßnahmen die dann auch sehr intensiv
freiheitsbeschränkungen haben für die
geimpften und da muss man dann überlegen
wenn doch die anderen mittel jetzt zum
beispiel nicht funktionieren sollten wie
3g in bus und bahn und so weiter kommt
man dann irgendwann nicht zu der stelle
wo man sagt auch die impfpflicht ist
letztlich ein milderes mittel
gesamtgesellschaftlich gesehen und kann
kommen im gegensatz eben dazu dass ich
sage jetzt mal so die geimpften
überspitzt gesagt weiter drangsaliert
werden für mich situation relativ
rechtlich im folgenden rahmen zu sehen
wir hatten jetzt zu beginnen im sommer
situation dass man quasi die kapazitäten
in den krankenhäusern waren in ordnung
so dass man sich gedacht hat na gut wer
sich nicht impft ist halt möglicherweise
in regelfalls gedacht ganz wenigen
ausnahmen vielleicht gute gründe aber im
regelfall im selber schuld
eigenverantwortung riskiert selbst
angesteckt zu werden die geimpften
selbst sind geschützt jetzt ist aber die
situation eben in zweierlei hinsicht
anders erstens sind weil die politik
versagt hat und keine booster impfung
frühzeitig möglich gemacht hat oder auf
den weg gebracht hat eben auch geimpfte
zunehmend etwas gefördert und zudem
haben wir einfach den fakt dass die
krankenhäuser immer voller werden so das
ist eben wirklich um das
gesundheitssystem als ganzes geht und da
kann man sich nicht mehr so einfach
hinstellen oder was ich auch vertreten
habe zu sagen ja die gefährden ja nur
sich selbst denn es ist eben nicht mehr
so sie gefährden einerseits andere die
sie auch anstrengen können und
andererseits kommt es eben zu den
engpässen auf intensivstationen zu
sondern wenn das jetzt noch weiter vor
dort und dann wenn man die anderen
maßnahmen irgendwann nichts bringen ist
die impfpflicht jedenfalls für bestimmte
berufsgruppen mit vielen kontakten
durchaus etwas was verhältnismäßig ist
es geht eben nicht das prinzip dass man
sagt so ja eine körperliche
unversehrtheit steht über allem und muss
auf jeden fall muss die körperliche
integrität gewahrt sein denn die kann
man sie und versichert ist eben nur
eines von vielen anderen grundrechten
und wenn man sagt wonach ist ja eben
aussieht dass diese impfung in aller
regel gefahrlos für das individuum
vonstatten geht es gibt immer im
einzelfall ausnahmen und wenn die aber
in der regel ganz gefahrlos ist was im
fall ist dann kann man eben über die
impfpflicht schon durchaus zumindest
diskutieren zumindest für bestimmte
berufsgruppen das wäre die frage aber
wenn es darum gehen sollte also
impfpflicht für bestimmte berufsgruppen
ist das also dann rechtlich ganz sauber
dass man also sagen kann ist dass fehr
auch ist das gerecht dass man sagen kann
die einen die müssen die säulen und die
anderen nicht wer entscheidet so was
dann das geht natürlich dann immer darum
irgendwie auch zu vergleichen sind das
berufsgruppen die viel in kontakt sind
mit eltern personen zum beispiel
pflegepersonal da muss es so in dieser
ungleichbehandlung die bei einer
impfpflicht für bestimmte berufsgruppen
und für eine nicht versteht und es einen
plausiblen grund grund geben dann ist es
möglich in frankreich gibt es ja auch so
einer eine impfpflicht
die andere frage ist natürlich wie man
die dann durchsetzen würde er hat man
würde ja so sicherheit niemanden die
polizei will nicht vorbeikommen
festhalten und die impfung verpassen so
wird es nicht laufen aber es würde eben
möglicherweise dann im strafen geben
bußgelder und so weiter so dass eben
dieser dieser druck dadurch nochmal
erhöht wird ja das wäre eben die die
möglichkeit es ist eine schwierige
abwägung da kann mich klar sache aber
dieses pauschale sagen wir können
unglaublich viele freiheitsrechte
anstellen wir können ausgangs
beschränkung machen fragte er nicht aber
in der vergangenheit wir können auch
kontakt beschränkungen machen leben
schließen und und lauter
freiheitsbeschränkung aber diese eine
freiheitsbeschränkung eine impfpflicht
können wir nicht machen das widerspricht
sich die politik auch ein stück weit
selbst denn wie die daten jetzt zeigen
ist das impfen in aller regel jedenfalls
mit biotech nicht gefährlich und dann
wird er diese körperliche unversehrtheit
wieder so als super grundrecht genommen
diesmal für die ungeimpften wo sie ja
vorher wo teilweise maßnahmen auch
übertrieben waren gegen groer allen
eingesetzt wurden also wegen corona
virus großer gefahr für leib und leben
aller grundrechte müssen erstmal
eingeschränkt werden selbst joggen im in
der nacht wird verboten das war ja auch
ein bisschen überbordend ja weil man ihm
gesagt hat leben und gesundheit ist die
voraussetzung für freiheit das ist
natürlich nicht richtig weil die
freiheit ist auch ein wert an sich und
nicht erst mal gesundheit dann freiheit
und umgekehrt geht es gleich jetzt
dieses frühe festlegungen der politik
impfpflicht wollen wir nicht in
deutschland
nimmt zumindest ein diskussions element
hier aus der öffentlichen debatte raus
muss halte ich nicht für sinnvoll ob es
um die impfpflicht für bestimmte
berufsgruppen auch wirklich heute da
gehen wird und ob das schon was
durchgesickert es würde ich gerne nicole
diekmann hauptstadtstudio
hauptstadtstudio korrespondentin in
berlin fragen die kulissen zu schauen
was in den papieren bekannt gewesen soll
darüber auch verhandelt werden
es sollte auf jeden fall darüber
verhandelt werden die unionsgeführten
länder haben diese debatte wohl heute
mit in diese
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz genommen
die forderung danach
personal quasi zur impfung zu
verpflichten das arbeitet in
pflegeheimen in krankenhäusern in
altenheimen mit
behinderten menschen mit besonders hohem
arabien so heißt das ja also besonders
empfindlichen anfälligen menschen
anfällig im sinne von für eine infektion
das ist ja felix hat das ja gerade sehr
anschaulich erklärt das ist ja politisch
total umstritten das ist ja aus diesem
grunde weil es so viel
gesellschaftlichen zündstoff auch
beinhaltet spaltung der gesellschaft ist
das stichwort
ausgeschlossen worden in der
vergangenheit da schien sich jetzt am
wochenende innerhalb der ampel die ja
noch über den koalitionsvertrag sitzt
etwas aufzuweichen
da sagte zb fdp chef lindner am sonntag
er würde sich da im moment noch gar
nicht gegen aussprechen wollen sondern
erstmal die expertenanhörung abwarten
die am montag im bundestag stattfinden
sollte dann presst die grünen vor katrin
göring eckardt sagte ja diese
impfpflicht für bestimmte berufsgruppen
das muss man ja immer dazu sagen werde
kommen musste dann aber am montag wieder
zurückrudern da sieht man also auch wie
umstritten dieses instrument ist aber um
es noch einmal zu sagen ich gehe davon
aus wir gehen davon aus dass es heute
bei der mindestens
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz ein thema
gewesen ist beziehungsweise vielleicht
ja auch gerade noch ist denn wir sehen
sehen wir nichts die pressekonferenz
fängt ja immer noch nicht an
ohne verzug zumindest die infos die wir
hatten wir viele nach geht's los aber
das gute ist es gibt so viele fragen von
euch im stream auch an nicole vielleicht
eine sache die wir kurz vor dem weg
schon sagen können weil martina hartwich
schreibt einen kommentar und fragt dann
also solange nur geredet wird werden die
zahlen nach oben schnellen unglaublich
dieses hin und her was ist konkret
beschlossen worden martina noch nichts
also wir warten noch auf die
pressekonferenz aber hier wirst du
erfahren und nicole wird das auch für
uns einordnen aber jetzt eine frage ganz
konkret auch noch mal an dich
mika ins bei youtube fragt habe ich das
richtig verstanden dass die festlegung
der regeln jetzt wieder ländersache ist
also können beispielsweise in berlin
ganz andere regeln als in brandenburg
herrschen
ja aber das war ja nie anders also die
länder haben ja auch in den vergangenen
monaten immer die instrumente an die
hand bekommen etwas zu beschließen das
haben sie im moment sowieso noch weil ja
noch die
die lage die nationalen lage epidemische
lage nationaler tragweite so ist es die
gilt ja noch bis nächsten donnerstag
die länder können im moment beschließen
die werden auch danach beschließen
können soll sich jetzt ändern dass sie
ihre parlamente wieder einbeziehen
müssen und auch das ihnen einige
instrumente nicht mehr an die hand
gegeben werden zum beispiel allgemeine
locker und schulen schließen restaurant
schließen und so weiter das will die
ampel nicht mal sehen ob das durchkommen
da sind wir beim infektionsschutzgesetz
dass er heute im bundestag in zweiter
und dritter lesung beschlossen wurde und
morgen in den bundesrat geht
also es ist nicht so dass jetzt in den
letzten monaten nur der bund beschlossen
hat so was ja nicht
wir haben noch eine andere frage was
zumindest zu dem was du jetzt schon
sagen kannst was du jetzt schon weißt du
mit den papieren und vorab infos die du
hast schon bei youtube fragt was ist mit
schulen also wird da auch heute darüber
diskutiert über kinder schulen und weil
wie es da vielleicht jetzt irgendwie
weitergeht es gibt einen punkt in diesem
papier in diesen papieren muss man ja
sagen ich hab's ja gesagt es gab gestern
schon eine beschlussvorlage die wir
bekommen haben es gab dann heute eine
neue 1 zum teil entschärfte eine zum
teil aber auch nachgeschärfte da ist zb
die rede von den sogenannten lolli tests
den pool tests die sollen die
formulierungen ist noch weiter
intensiviert werden
das ist an manchen stellen in diesem
papier so es soll auch noch schärfer
heißt es kontrolliert werden ob 2g und
3g regeln eingehalten werden da muss man
sagen das ist natürlich politische
krisen kommunikation denn die kontrollen
sind ja hört man aus allen ecken weiß
man auch selber aus der eigenen
erfahrung bei weitem nicht so wie sie
eigentlich sein sollten dasselbe gilt
auch für die tests in schulen und kitas
da könnte das noch sehr viel luft nach
oben was das angeht die zielmarke ist
und das ist da herrscht weitestgehend
einigkeit zumindest in der politik die
kitas und die schulen offen zu lassen
obwohl die instanzen auch das gehört
dazu gerade in der altersgruppe
derjenigen bis zwölf vor allen dingen
die ja noch nicht geimpft werden da
wartet man ja quasi stündlich auf die
zulassung die instanzen gehen durch die
decke in kitas und schulen und trotzdem
nochmal man hat im lotto und gesehen
dass gerade kinder aus problematischen
familien auch aus bildungsfernen
familien enorm darunter leiden dass die
hinterher hängen was den unterricht
angeht wenn es zum homeschooling kommt
oder auch zum wechsel unterricht
psychische probleme wurden da breit
diskutiert also das will man verhindern
danke nicole du sax uns bescheid wenn
sich was tut bei der pressekonferenz
dann werden wir natürlich danach wieder
sprechen was das angesprochen die
instanzen gehen durch die decke also die
zahlen steigen und auch da hat sich der
robert-koch-institut präsident lothar
wieler gestern noch einmal zu der ganzen
corona lage geäußert
von diesen 52.000 dort werden und da ist
nichts mehr daran zu ändern 400 etwas
sterben ja in der bpk habe ich das ein
bisschen
zurückhaltender gesagt mindestens 200
und was mir wichtig ist das müssen alle
die jetzt zu hören ganz klar begreifen
daran gibt es nichts mehr zu ändern
wir können das nicht mehr ändern das ist
ein eimer wasser der ist ausgeschüttet
dann kriegen sie nicht mehr rein
gehört dem robert-koch-institut
koch instituts präsident lothar wieder
und können jetzt mit frau professor falk
noch ein bisschen weiter sprechen frau
professor falk ist das vielleicht auch
ein problem das sich alle nachdem es die
info impfungen gab vielleicht zu sorglos
gefühlt haben
also diese aussage betrifft hier alle
menschen die infiziert waren und gestern
und in den letzten tagen mit diesen sehr
hohen zahlen gemeldet wurden bevor man
bevor ich darauf antworte ist noch mal
ein punkt ganz wichtig ja überwiegend
der anteil dieser menschen ist aus der
gruppe der ungeimpften und es ist nur im
moment wir warten jede minute auf den
wochenbericht vom robert-koch-institut
letzte woche war es so dass nur 0,3
prozent der geimpften menschen im
durchbrüchen das heißt über 99 prozent
der menschen die geimpften haben keinen
impft durchbruch also das ist der eine
punkt es ist also nicht so dass die
geimpften jetzt sozusagen diese
krankenhaus belastung darstellen sondern
es gibt bundesländer wie sachsen die das
getrennt ausweisen und die instanzen
einmal ausweisen für die ungeimpfte
gruppe und einmal für die geimpften
gruppe unter sieht man eben dass es da
ein über zehnfachen unterschied gibt
also sind die menschen die sich jetzt so
infizieren überwiegt nach wie vor aus
der gruppe der ungeimpften da sind
natürlich leider auch kinder unter zwölf
dabei war wie für die noch gar keinen
zugelassenen impfstoff haben und da ist
es eben leider sehr wohl so dass je
nachdem wie man jetzt auch unter der
delta variante berechnen kann wie viele
menschen müssen denn ins krankenhaus und
intensiv pflichtig werden sind es 0,7
prozent der menschen die sich infizieren
die eine intensivbehandlung brauchen und
davon stirbt noch mal leider ein anteil
daher kommen die zahlen die herr wieder
genannt hat wenn wir über 50.000
infizierte haben dann ist damit zu
rechnen und das ist wie er gesagt hat
das wird leider so kommen auch wenn man
es nicht möchte dass dann doch 200
menschen nicht mehr weihnachten neben
werden so hart hat es formuliert weil
eben doch auch wenn wir jetzt jüngere
menschen haben sich anstecken immer noch
genügend dabei sind die einen schweren
verlauf haben unter der jüngeren gruppe
können wir nicht vorhersagen wer einen
schweren verlauf das sind nicht nur
leute die vorerkrankungen haben und
deswegen ist es leider so dass die
zahlen immer schon eine vorausschau
leider ermöglichen wie viele menschen
intensivbetten benötigen werden da sagt
didi wie die deutsche
intensivmedizinische gesellschaft
zurecht die haben wir dann nicht wenn es
so weitergeht und wie viele menschen
leider dann weihnachten oder neuer nicht
mehr erleben werden das sind schon
zahlen finde ich bei denen man doch
wirklich merken muss dass wir handeln
müssen damit sich nicht so viele
menschen anstecken und wie gesagt der
größte teil kommt aus der gruppe der
ungeimpften deswegen ist mir auch so
wichtig zu sagen leute wenn ihr euch
nicht anstecken wollt dann müsst ihr
euch bitte impfen lassen weil sich so
durchzumogeln wird in diesem winter
nicht funktionieren
winter stichwort das weihnachtsfest und
die weihnachtsferien auch erik meijer
bei youtube fragt gibt es valide zahlen
die gut 2 g + schützt also geimpft und
getestet ist das für beispielsweise die
weihnachtsferien ein sicheres konzept
das ist auf jeden fall das beste konzept
das wir jetzt an der anti menschen an
die hand geben können und zwar einfach
deshalb weil zweimal impfen ja schon
sehr gut wirkt und auch schützt wir
warten auf den bericht des lka heute
abend aber letzte woche war es so dass
immerhin die menschen die
sind haben über 70 prozent schutz auch
vor infektionen in deutschland egal was
in israel passiert im moment haben wir
noch diese situation also wir sind wir
merken der druck steigt auf die gruppe
der geimpften aber der schutz ist schon
noch da wir laufen langsam aus dieser
phase raus deswegen sind die auf
richtungen so wichtig also die impfung
ist schon mal der erste schritt und wenn
wir dann noch das testen dazu nehmen
dann können wir wirklich auch den besten
versuch unternehmen menschen die
infektion sind herauszufischen damit die
das virus nicht an andere weitergeben
daher würde man auf jeden fall plädieren
das 2g plus die sicherste möglichkeit
ist die wir haben und ich würde an der
stelle gern noch mal so ein bisschen
wieder die idee der
tests noch mal nach vorne bringen sind
die ordentlich gemacht sind und nicht
nur hier oben an den nüstern sozusagen
sondern richtig in die nase rein oder
vielleicht vorher in den rachen und dann
in die nase kann man tatsächlich sehr
gut auch selber feststellen ob man virus
hat dass man im ernstfall weitergeben
würde oder ob man wirklich gerade nicht
infektiös ist und wenn wir einen eltern
noch mal zu gute halten dass sie das mit
den schulkindern schon geübt haben dann
wissen die meisten menschen ewig diese
tests funktionieren und wenn man die
ordentlich macht kann man sie auch
nehmen die sind keine hundertprozentige
sicherheit aber wir können wirklich
dieses instrument dazu nehmen um noch
mal ein bisschen zu versuchen virus
ausbreitung zu verhindern
daher würde ich dieses konzept auf jeden
fall befürworten gerade auch für ferien
und andere aktivitäten
und stichwort tests haben angesprochen
wie wichtig das ist dass man natürlich
die selbsttests auch wirklich da
ordentlich ausführt es gibt aber auch so
ja noch eine andere art von test der
sogenannte antikörper test gibt es eine
eine frage von freier bei youtube sie
fragt wäre es nicht sinnvoller dass alle
den antikörper test durchführen vor
allem auch geimpfte dann kann man
nachweisen wie gut man geschützt ist
beziehungsweise die impfung wirkt
das ist eine sehr gute frage und
natürlich ich bin ja selbst
experimentelle immunologie und
naturwissenschaftlerinnen ja klar es
wäre natürlich theoretisch sinnvoll zu
sagen wir messen dann können wir ja auch
sehen wie er hat sehr viele antikörper
wer hat weniger antikörper ist und so
genannte low responder und wer hat unter
umständen keine was bei immun gesunden
menschen ja nicht der fall ist es ist
aber so dass ist nicht pragmatisch es
ist sehr kostenintensiv und dann fängt
die diskussion um grenzwerte an das
heißt theoretisch wäre das schon möglich
aber diese antikörper sind nur so das
beste maß dass wir haben aber sie sind
auch nicht absolut
aussagekräftig aber wir sehen zum
beispiel und da macht es sinn bei den
menschen die wirklich auch ein
möglicherweise eingeschränktes
immunsystem haben transplantierte mit
medikamenten oder krebs patienten die
medikamente bekommen da macht es in der
tat sind da wird es auch gemacht denn da
muss man tatsächlich feststellen dass es
ja menschen gibt die keine immunreaktion
aufbauen können weil sie medikamente
nehmen
und das zu definieren ist besonders
wichtig das machen wir hier auch mit den
transplantierten auch mit dem krebs
patientinnen und patienten dass es also
ein wichtiger baustein für die leute die
ein gesundes immunsystem haben ist es
zwar möglich aber es ist nicht eine
pragmatische lösung weil wir da einfach
sehen die meisten menschen haben sehr
gute antikörper die neben mit der zeit
etwas ab und bevor man da jetzt anfängt
herauszufinden wer soll gewusst hat
werden wir also nicht wie kommuniziert
man das wichtiges thema ist der
pragmatische schritt nach vorne zu sagen
wir haben angefangen mit den älteren
personen und denen die ein höheres
risiko haben diese auffrischimpfung zu
empfehlen und jetzt geht es dann auch
mit der stiko empfehlung die jetzt bald
rauskommt auf alle menschen ab 18 jahren
denen zu sagen wenn so ungefähr ein
halbes jahr vorbei ist sechs monate sind
so kein stichtag aber so ein großer
zeitraum den man da an legt macht eine
dritte impfung auf jeden fall sind dann
braucht man da nicht bei jeder einzelnen
person erst messen und sich dann zu
überlegen macht es sinn oder nicht
sondern pragmatisch es dann tatsächlich
zu sagen wir nehmen mit der dritten
impfung quasi noch mal einen
zusätzlichen auf frisch effekt mit
schützen damit möglichst viele menschen
ganz besonders gut und dann werden wir
auch dazu beitragen dass die zahlen
wieder runter gehen weil es auch ein
wichtiger beitrag dazu ist die virus
ausbreitung zu verhindern
sie haben es angesprochen also die
auffrischimpfung darüber wird auch
wirklich viel diskutiert und da gibt es
viele fragen nach wie vor bei uns im
stream ein user mit einem sehr
interessanten namen hempels hinter nennt
er sich fragt sich was ist nach den
nachdem boostern wie viele jahre sollte
ich mich postern lassen ist überhaupt
ein ende abzusehen
das ist ehrlicher weise eine frage die
wir in der immunologie auch sehr heftig
diskutieren weil wir natürlich auch uns
fragen wie ist das mit der immunität
langfristig die ehrliche antwort ist
dass wir gesehen haben wie gut die
impfung wirkt und jetzt sehen wir dass
die frage wie gut sie schützt auch davon
abhängt wie wie aggressiv ist sozusagen
die virus lage und deswegen sind es
immer zwei dinge die zusammenspiel der
impfschutz perse und dann die frage
wieviel viruslast view wie hoch ist die
welle die da auf uns zurollt und
deswegen ist es so dass die im moment
sagen würden wir müssen jetzt über
diesen winter kommen weil wir haben ja
einen sehr starken saisonalen effekt das
heißt in dem moment wo es frühling wird
und dann sommer wird gehen die zahlen
auch runter deswegen ist es jetzt
wichtig zu sagen für diesen winter
brauchen wir definitiv diese dritte
impfung dann werden wir lernen wie hoch
wir da sozusagen in der entwicklung
kommen was die antikörper angeht und
dass sie mit den immunstatus quasi und
wie lange der sich heldt wir verfolgen
ja alle deutschland und weltweit diese
leute die geimpft sind kontinuierlich
weiter
und da wird man sehen ob wir dann im
nächsten frühjahr sagen mit den drei
impfungen haben wir wirklich so ein
hohes niveau erreicht das dann noch ein
ganzes jahr hält oder sind wir dann doch
wieder in der lage dass wir sagen wenn
die hohe zahlen hätten was ich nicht
hoffe aber dann müssen wir vielleicht
für den herbst/winter nächstes jahr doch
noch mal eine art auffrischung wieder
machen das kann ich nicht vorhersagen
wir werden das sehr genau beobachten und
schon rechtzeitig darauf hinweisen
vielleicht gibt mir das noch die
gelegenheit gerade zu sagen dass es
nicht ein man kann vielleicht nicht
sagen das ist ein generelles
politikversagen war wir haben die
booster impfung wir haben im sommer
gemerkt es gibt menschen die machen
keine antwort um die haben wir uns
gekümmert da gibt es nicht die kuh
empfehlung weltweit war das so dass war
august diese diskussion israel ist
vorangegangen das ist richtig weil sie
gesehen haben dass die zahlen so hoch
gehen aber wir haben auch abgewartet ob
die sicherheitsdaten da sind denn
natürlich kann man auch nur eine
auffrischimpfung empfehlen wenn man
gleichzeitig sagen kann wie sicher die
ist und dass sie das sicherheitsniveau
hält was wir von der ersten und zweiten
impfung kennen auch das braucht dann
noch mal und dann reden wir von
september/oktober und jetzt sind wir in
der lage dass wir sagen okay bei den
hohen zahlen müssen wir da jetzt
auffrischimpfungen also ich würde nicht
generell einfach sagen das war ein
politikversagen sondern wir haben das
alle sehr intensiv diskutiert und die
umsetzung zwischen immunologie medizin
und politik ist etwas was ich auch
gelernt habe ist einfach ein sehr
dynamisches fällt würde ich einfach mal
sagen
es gibt noch mehr fragen frau professor
falk ich habe das gefühl wir könnten
wirklich hier ewig reden vielleicht
müssen wir das ja auch weil er bei der
pressekonferenz tut sich nach wie vor
nichts aber es ist ja spannend dass wir
sie heute zu gast haben und sie uns all
diese fragen beantworten können und zwar
möchte eine userin lucia bei youtube
wissen wieso wird nicht mehr auf
medikamente gesetzt und endlich mal ein
anderer impfstoff zugelassen
auch sehr gute fragen medikamente zuerst
es gibt medikamente die im moment im
zulassungsverfahren sind es gibt auch
eine stellungnahme der leopoldina also
der akademie der wissenschaften unter
der führung von gerald haug und frau
riebsamen chefs die eine gruppe von
menschen zusammengebracht haben um zu
sagen wir müssen genau diesen punkt
kommunizieren dieses papier ist
vorletzte woche raus gekommen da es
völlig klar dass auch deutschland sich
darum kümmern muss dass es medikamente
gibt zwei medikamentenklassen sind
gerade in den zulassungsverfahren das
eine wurde von der europäischen behörde
auch gerade zugelassen das sind
antikörper die man nicht selber bildet
nach der impfung sondern die schon
bereits hergestellt werden und diese
antikörper die bekanntesten vielleicht
die die der ex präsident donald trump
bekommen hat diese antikörper ersetzen
quasi wenn man auch selber keine
immunität hat dann kann man antikörper
geben damit schon mal ein antikörper
schutz besteht die man quasi mit einer
injektion verabreichen kann das ist eine
behandlung die macht nur sinn früh nach
infektionen und da gibt es wieder diese
risikogruppen also menschen die keine
eigene immunantwort aufbauen können
denen kann man auf die sprünge helfen
sozusagen durch die gabe dieser fertigen
antikörper die mit der injektion
verabreicht werden da ist also die
zulassung der europäischen behörde da
das wird auch zum teil schon umgesetzt
die bundesregierung hat ich hoffe es ist
richtig im kopf 200.000 dosen das weiß
ich nicht ganz genauso in dem dreh schon
bereitgestellt die gibt es in
deutschland schon die sind gekauft aber
das ist etwas was mit einer infusion
gegeben werden muss also im krankenhaus
und aufwändig aber das ist möglich es
gibt zwei medikamente die direkt am
virus angreifen das gute an dem virus
ist ja das virus muss sich vermehren
dazu braucht es ganz viele
eiweißmoleküle die es wieder
zusammenbasteln quasi und da gibt es
zwei medikamente die da angreifen das
eine ist ein molekül das verhindert dass
das virus sich zusammenbauen kann das
virus bildet erst mal eine ganz große
eiweiß kette und schnitzel die dann mit
so einer molekularen schere in kleine
stückchen und die bilden ein neues virus
und wenn man diese schere blockiert dann
kann man verhindern dass das virus sich
vermehrt das ist es ein medikament von
das andere medikament ist wenn das virus
sich vermehrt muss es ja seine eigene
genetische information ablesen und
vervielfältigen und dieses
vervielfältigen kann man dadurch
blockieren indem man das virus zwingend
fehler zu machen so dass es sich nicht
mehr ordentlich vermehren kann das ist
die zweite art von
medikamenten auch das ist im moment im
zulassungsverfahren also ja es gibt
diese entwicklung interessanterweise
braucht aber so eine
medikamentenentwicklung noch mehr zeit
als eine impfung und zwar deshalb weil
sie bei jedem virus von vorne anfangen
müssen um die substanz zu finden die
diese zwei eiweißstoffe diese zwei
enzyme tatsächlich blockieren kann also
es gibt diese entwicklung die sind auf
dem weg aber in diesem jahr ist es nicht
zu erwarten dass die schon zugelassen
sind auch in deutschland verfügbar sind
also dass es etwas was wir haben werden
in zukunft hoffentlich die daten über
die wirkung sehen sehr gut aus trotzdem
würde ich immer sagen ganz ehrlich wenn
ich mich davor schützen kann mich mit so
einem virus zu infizieren ist mir dass
der liebe weg dann habe ich es nämlich
gar nicht immer im körper bevor ich rein
lasse und dann muss ich gucken dass ich
wieder loswerde wäre es mir einfach
lieber zu sagen dann ist die impfung
doch eine sehr schlaue idee da
verhindere ich in den meisten fällen
dass ich das ding überhaupt einfangen
vielen dank frau professor falk zunächst
mal für den moment wir sprechen schon so
lange das sie ungeduldig angerufen
werden sie haben einen kurzen moment
auch die an um zurückzurufen
es soll in fünf minuten so hören wir
angeblich dann auch die pressekonferenz
losgehen mal schauen ob das stimmt aber
es gibt auch noch mehr fragen nicht so
zum impfen sondern wir haben eben auch
noch mehr fragen zu den maßnahmen die
sonst noch kommen könnten und die kann
uns felix zimmermann unser experte von
recht und justiz hier am besten
beantworten deswegen
zu dem
versagen also was sie hier abstreiten
das ist sicher richtig dass ordentlich
testen muss auf die sicherheit besteht
die sicherheitsregeln bestehen aber es
ist ja auch so dass israel ist doch
offensichtlich ist ein sportlicher
unterwegs war das schon gemacht haben
aber es ist ja so dass das
politikversagen dadurch besteht dass das
ganze nicht vorbereitet wurde also wir
haben ja die situation dass man
jedenfalls die tritt die notwendigkeit
der tritt impfung für möglich gehalten
hat und das kann doch doch jetzt sehr
überraschend plötzlich von gefühlt ja
mal vom einen auf den anderen tag die
treppe empfang ist nötig wo ist die rund
metaller geimpften geht jetzt sofort
booster impfung die testzentren sind
teilweise geschlossen worden also ich
dass politik versagen wenn ich jetzt
nicht das abwarten und den leuten
bedenken dort etwas verpassen sondern
die vorbereitung auf diese naheliegende
eventualität die prozedurale absicherung
das ist das so sagen was ich meinte auch
nicht dass man auf eine auf eine
notwendige sicherung prüfung verzichten
sollte man schauen ob wir heute mehr
klarheit bei diesen themen bekommen
felix ich hatte vorhin ein bisschen in
den kommentaren geguckt und wir haben
eben nicht nur viele fragen zum impfen
wir haben also auch fragen zu den
maßnahmen die jetzt also vielleicht
wieder kommen sollen oder dies neu gibt
so möchte julian götz bei youtube wissen
wann gibt es wieder home office und
dadurch weniger
großveranstaltungen so hat er es genannt
also wie das jetzt blickt habe ist es so
dass eben die ampelkoalition in diesem
gesetzentwurf gesagt hat wir brauchen
wieder mehr home office und den
arbeitgebern zu viel schwierigen
bedingungen ermöglicht hat davon
abzuweichen ich muss mich die zwingende
gründe geben warum der arbeitnehmer die
arbeitnehmerin vor ort sein mussten das
ist so quasi der der die neue regelung
und ja dass das gilt sobald das gesetz
dann verkündet ist und der große
versammlungen das ist wiederum was
anderes war die versandte
versammlungsverbot
versammlungsverbote aufgrund von coop 19
infektionen das ist eher etwas was
ausgeschlossen wurde von von der ampel
solche demonstrationen und so weiter
sollen stattfinden können allerdings
wohl auch mit der erwägung dass die eben
meistens dann draußen stattfinden und da
zeigte durchaus die forschung dass da
die gefahr doch stark reduziert ist
spannend dass du das noch erwähnt hast
ich glaube sogar nur er meinte mit gross
versammlung im büro offensichtlich
arbeitet er im büro musste zugeben muss
lustig zugeht das ist ja eigentlich
schön es gab von holger fiel per mail
fragen nämlich genau stichwort also
arbeit und jetzt es gibt ja auch leute
die können nicht uns ins home office die
müssen also täglich ins büro oder wo
auch immer ihre arbeitsstätte ist und
jetzt fragte also holger piel wenn das
so kommen sollte dass es dann neue
regeln gibt ob der arbeitgeber für die
impfung in bezahlt freistellen würde ihn
oder andere grundsätzlich war die frage
für die impfung bezahlt verstehen wenn
er zur impfung geht in der arbeitszeit
in der arbeitszeit
darf eigentlich nicht aus bin allerdings
jetzt auch keinen
arbeitsrechtsexperte was solche
detailfragen angeht aber das impfen ist
ja zumal etwas was eine persönliche
persönliche sache ist da wenn jetzt im
arbeitsvertrag steht stünde du musst
dich impfen lassen abgesehen davon ob
das zulässig wäre oder nicht dann wäre
es eine arbeitsvertragliche geschichte
dann könnte man sagen dass sie zur
arbeitszeit ja aber die das impfen an
sich das ist ja eine persönliche
angelegenheit das meines erachtens ist
das nicht der fall es gegen außerdem ihm
auch noch er hat noch eine zweite frage
gestellt nicht nur um das impfen in der
arbeitszeit sondern er hatte auch fragen
und zwar was das testen anbelangt und
zwar zählt die zeit beim test im
testzentrum vor der arbeit und der
kollege ist offensichtlich behinderte
wie sie mich wirklich auf jede minute
ankommt die er dann beim arbeitgeber
sagen kann da habe ich aber gearbeitet
wir sehen es wirklich stechuhr auch
erfunden worden weil im moment moment
die frage ist noch nicht fertig ist es
spannend und es betrifft ja auch noch
viele menschen deswegen also ich stelle
keine zählt die zeit beim test im
testzentrum vor der arbeit wenn das
testzentrum erst nach arbeitsbeginn
aufmacht zur bezahlten arbeitszeit also
hier ist die lage so wenn das quasi zum
zum
arbeitsvertrag auch gehirn würde dann
könnte man das sagen solange wenn es
aber eine eine politische regel ist
die auf den weg gebracht wurde dann eher
nicht aber ich bin ganz offen die frage
hat sich final nicht beantworten das ist
ja auch alles noch nicht entschieden das
sind ja auch dinge
arbeitsvertraglicher art die werden ja
von den gerichten dann ganz
unterschiedlich bewertet jetzt wie zum
beispiel jetzt erst jüngst das
bundesarbeitsgericht gesagt hat dass ein
allgemeiner lockdown dazu führt dass ein
arbeitgeber welche weise ein
arbeitnehmer in bestimmten fällen nicht
mehr bezahlen was das haben die eine
instanzen so gesehen und so weiter also
die allgemein verbindlichen regeln sind
für diese bereiche auch noch nicht durch
die ganzen instanzen gegangen so dass
man das jetzt nicht mit sicherheit sagen
kann ich schon noch mal in den
kommentare ob wir vielleicht auch gerade
hier zu diesem umfeld noch mehr haben
das würde ich mich hier mal durch also
na ja vielleicht gehen wir aber auch
noch mal einen schritt weiter also jetzt
weg vom arbeitsplatz und zwar nochmal
zurück zum impfen jonas z schreibt bei
youtube und zwar mit einem fragezeichen
zweig plus für alle fragezeichen wäre es
denn so einfach zu sagen zweig plus geht
jetzt für alle menschen in deutschland
gut kommt auf an welchem welchen bereich
wenn das jetzt die altenpflege ist oder
die krankenhäuser da kann man sicherlich
darüber nachdenken aber dass eine
bundesweite zweig plus für den
supermarkt ich muss im supermarkt gibt
auch einen test machen das greift dann
eben alles in freiheitsrechte der
ungeimpften unter geimpften ein mit dem
aspekt dass die geimpften ja wirklich
schon sich solidarisch verhalten haben
durch die impfung und dann muss man auch
wirklich gucken ist das im einzelfall
notwendig wenn natürlich die
chemische lage sich weiter verschärft
und immer mehr belastung kommen ist
natürlich zweig plus eine dann immer
noch verhältnismäßig milde maßnahme da
man kann ja immer noch alles tun muss
eben im vorfeld sich testen lassen aber
es ist trotzdem natürlich wesentliche
einschränkung nicht nur irgendwie
spontan wohin zu gehen erstmalig einen
test zu holen das ist eine einschränkung
aber natürlich immer noch milder als die
dinge ganz zu schließen wie es in der
vergangenheit auch passiert ist jetzt
gibt es hier so ein bisschen
detailfragen und vollkommen in ordnung
wenn du das jetzt detail nicht
beantworten kann sich das noch und zwar
in sachen nämlich änderungen
infektionsschutzgesetz dabei ja zum
einen die rede eben von den tests am
arbeitsplatz aber eben auch von den
tests in bus und bahn und hier fragt
sich jetzt zum einen der dickkopf bei
youtube was heißt test am arbeitsplatz
schnell oder pcr test wurde das so
konkret überhaupt benannt ja das ist so
ein bisschen unklar ich habe das jetzt
nicht ich habe das jetzt vielleicht weil
es dann die kölner mehr ich habe das
jetzt noch nicht ganz erfasst ist
teilweise steht auch selbst test ist
möglich das habe ich jetzt nicht ganz
überblickt was das was da zu treffen und
dann ist es ja bus und bahn also auch da
sollte auf jeden fall jetzt dann drei
gekommen lucy bei youtube fragt wie soll
das in bus und bahn funktionieren für
berufstätige ein test am bahnhof ist
sowas überhaupt so konkret gemacht
worden oder ist das jetzt noch mal eine
ausgestaltung die jetzt erst dann
passiert ja da ist natürlich jetzt die
frage auf wie alt muss der test sein 24
stunden hört man und dann ist vor allem
die frage wieso das denn jetzt dann
kontrolliert werden ja es wird
sicherlich nicht so sein das ist ja dann
auch ein erhöhtes infektionsrisiko
dass die leute bevor sie jetzt in den
zug steigen getestet werden schwierig zu
kontrollieren
dann muss sich das vorstellen was da
geht er schafft natürlich das ist nicht
seine aufgabe nach einem nach einem so
die jedenfalls im öffentlichen
nahverkehr angeht ist ja nicht die
aufgabe nämlich einen impf stativ karten
zu fragen das stelle ich mir schon
schwierig vor allerdings ist ja denkbar
dass eben die zusätzliche kompetenz
bekommen jetzt zum beispiel der
deutschen bahn zu sagen ja bitte wo ist
denn hier im nachweis oder die test
nachweis und wenn nicht wird die zugeben
angehalten das passiert ja auch mehrfach
schon in der
letzten wochen dass personen die
irgendwie masken nicht tragen dass der
zug gestoppt und die leute
rausgeschmissen werden also möglich ist
das aber das ist natürlich eine riesige
herausforderung die da auf der
öffentlichen verkehrsbetriebe
anzukommen zurollt und überhaupt das ist
ja das problem auch an den maßnahmen man
sieht wenn ich jetzt hier letzte woche
in berlin war und hatten eine bar
gegangen bin da wird man zwar gefragt ja
ordentlich nachdem im zertifikat
personalausweis wird aber eigentlich
keiner sehen ja und natürlich auch dass
sie sagen ob ich heute was auch ein
minister konferenz beraten die strafen
ja
50 euro oder 100 euro sind so dann ist
wie die sanktions wirkung gering nicht
an solche maßnahmen zu halten und dann
muss schon irgendwie ein bisschen mehr
kommen um eine sogenannte lenkung kommt
dann auch herbeizuführen dem änderungen
im infektionsschutzgesetz sie müssen ja
auch erstmal morgen vom bundesrat auch
noch abgesegnet werden was passiert denn
wenn der nein sagt wenn da nichts
rauskommt wir haben einen seite kommt
also das neue gesetz nicht auf den weg
dann läuft dann wie nicola grad schon
gesagt hat nächste woche die fdp
logische
nachweisen sondern geradeaus und dann
gilt eine klausel im
infektionsschutzgesetz nachdem die
länder wieder quasi die möglichkeit
haben bestimmungen zu treffen also dann
kommt es wieder auf das jeweilige land
an ohne dass es das spezielle vorgaben
des bundes gibt wie jetzt zum beispiel
keine ausgangs beschränkung das heißt
insofern hätten die länder dann wieder
mehr möglichkeiten was zu machen
unabhängig vom vom bund und wenn es
durch geht geht es dann ab sofort wie
ist das das gilt dann nachdem es vom
bundespräsidenten verschrieben
unterschrieben und im gesetzblatt
verkündet wurde und dann geht es quasi
sofort danke felix und jetzt tatsächlich
dann doch beginnt auch die
pressekonferenz und wir können hin
schalten und hören uns danach wieder zur
einordnung also hier nun die
pressekonferenz zum bund länder treffen
die mission tag
ja meine damen und herren ist war sehr
wichtig dass wir heute die konferenz
zwischen bund und ländern hatten sie
sehen an der konstellation der
pressekonferenz ja dass wir uns in einer
besonderen phase befinden einer
geschäftsführenden bundesregierung einer
entstehenden neuen bundesregierung und
das drückt sich auch jetzt hier in
dieser pressekonferenz aus aber wir
haben diese konferenz auch im
bewusstsein abgehalten dass es dem
währungs vollkommen egal ist ob
deutschland sich gerade in einer phase
mit geschäftsführender bundesregierung
befindet oder verhandlungen zur bildung
einer neuen stattfinden und es ihm auch
egal wer sich wie weit schon in seinen
politischen überzeugungen bewegt hat
sondern entscheiden tut nur was diebe
richtigen und wichtigen maßnahmen sind
und deshalb war heute das einzige
kriterium unserer beratung auch dass wir
mitten in der vierten welle uns mit der
aktuellen dramatischen
infektions situation in deutschland
befassen und daraus die möglichst besten
schlussfolgerungen ziehen das betrifft
zum einen die eindämmung des
exponentiellen anstieg und das betrifft
zum anderen das schnelle impfen im
zusammenhang mit der
auffrischungsimpfung zum ersten muss man
sagen dass wir eine wirklich
besorgniserregende situation haben die
es nicht in deutschland gleich verteilt
sondern zwischen den bundesländern gibt
es eine instanz spanne von 117 bis
911 aber tatsache ist dass die
bundesweite verdopplung zeit jetzt 13
tage betrug und die verdopplung zeit der
belegung von intensivbetten etwa 23 24
tage und wir wissen damit dass wir uns
eine weitere verdopplung zeit bei der
belegung von intensivbetten nicht
erlauben können das heißt wir brauchen
einen schnellen
stopp oder einbremsen des exponentiellen
an steaks und dem dienen alle beschlüsse
die wir heute gefasst haben natürlich
dient dem auch wenn es darüber
unterschiedliche meinungen gibt das
infektionsschutzgesetz was jetzt heute
im deutschen bundestag und
verabschiedet wurde und morgen im
bundesrat beraten wurde wir wissen und
das ist bedauerlich wir könnten besser
dastehen wenn die impflücken nicht so
groß wäre und deshalb werden viele
maßnahmen die jetzt ergriffen werden
müssen nicht notwendig gewesen denn wer
mehr geimpfte menschen hätten und es ist
nie zu spät sich impfen zu lassen auch
jetzt kann man noch mit einer
erstimpfung einen guten beitrag für sich
und für die gemeinschaft leisten
bei den beschlüssen die wir heute
gefasst haben ging es also als erstes um
das impfen hier ist heute die
auffrischungsimpfung auch noch mal von
der ständigen impfkommission bewertet
worden und für alle empfohlen die älter
als 18 sind und zwischen fünf und sechs
monate zurückliegen nach der letzten im
nach der zweiten impfung das ist eine
gute nachricht weil da hat natürlich
auch für alle mehr sicherheit eintritt
aber es ist eine herausfordernde
nachricht weil nunmehr eine große zahl
von menschen
mit einer solchen auffrischungsimpfung
versehen werden muss das sind etwa noch
27 millionen impfungen wenn man überlegt
wie viele menschen bis zum 31 bis zum 30
juni
2021 schon geimpft waren vier millionen
haben wir schon das heißt 27 millionen
bleiben etwa übrig bund und länder
verpflichten sich jedem ein angebot zu
machen und das bedarf einer wirklichen
großen kraftanstrengung die
cds werden gemeinsam als chefs der
staatskanzleien wenn gemeinsam mit den
gesundheitsministern bis zur regulären
cds konferenz der nächsten woche
eine planung vornehmen wie das geschehen
kann welche fragestellungen sich auftun
wo unterstützt werden muss thw
katastrophenschutz haben ihre
unterstützung heute auch angeboten und
wir werden dann versuchen hier wirklich
eine große sicherheit hinzubekommen es
wir haben uns befasst mit den
verschiedenen aspekten des lebens ist
will ich hier nicht alles darf das auch
im infektionsschutzgesetz geregelt ist
3g am arbeitsplatz die frage der
öffentlichen personennahverkehrs anderes
aber ich will sagen ein großer zweck der
heutigen ministerpräsidenten konferenz
war ja wann muss muss das
instrumentarium angewendet werden dass
wir im infektionsschutzgesetz zur
verfügung haben und da haben wir heute
wie ich finde sehr sehr gute beschlüsse
gefasst wir haben nämlich schwellen
derzeit definiert ab denen dann eine
bestimmte
flächendeckendem maßnahmenkatalog
eingesetzt werden muss das beginnt bei
einem hospitalisierung des index sie
wissen dass der für uns setzen
maßgebliche größe ist von 3 denn der
überschritten wird dann muss zweig
flächendeckend eingeführt werden das
heißt also geimpft oder getestet bei den
gesamten veranstaltungen und ähnlich
geimpft und genesen entschuldigung ja
und bei einem schwellenwert von 6 beim
hospitalisierung des index wird das
ergänzt durch zweig plus das heißt auch
die geimpften und genesen müssen
getestet werden und wenn der
hospitalisierung index neuen
überschreitet da geht es dann
vorbehaltlich der zustimmung der
landtage natürlich weil die dann
sozusagen oder auch notwendig sind nach
der konstruktion des jetzigen
infektionsschutzgesetzes bei einem
schwellenwert von über 9 beim
hospitalisierung index muss an das
gesamte instrumentarium der
möglichkeiten eingesetzt also kontakt
beschränkungen und verschiedene
einschränkungen
hier ist ja kein geheimnis wenn ich der
meinung dass dieser katalog nicht
ausreicht aber wir haben dann auch eine
vereinbarung getroffen auf die hervis
noch näher eingehen wird das im laufe
der zeit ja die dinge auch wieder
überprüft werden können und es ist sehr
gut dass im infektionsschutzgesetz
enthalten ist eine regelung dass bis zum
15 dezember das ist insbesondere für
sachsen jetzt sehr wichtig maßnahmen die
jetzt noch eingeführt werden auch dann
gelten können es ist wichtig dass bürger
test kostenlos natürlich angeboten
werden und wir haben uns noch einmal
auch bereit erklärt dass wir bei den
pflegekräften im zusammenhang mit der
intensivpflege insbesondere einen bonus
zahlen werden und wir haben heute eine
vereinbarung getroffen die
eine die eine länder bitte ist nämlich
dass das personal in pflegeeinrichtungen
geimpft sein soll das heißt also hier
wird der bund in kürze befinden die wir
uns zu verhalten
aber das ist natürlich eine sehr
wichtige mitteilung alles in allem haben
wir damit heute einen ganz großen
maßnahmenkatalog wie ich finde
verabredet ich sage allerdings die lage
ist hochdramatisch und es wird jetzt
sehr darauf ankommen dass schnell
gehandelt wird das konsequent gehandelt
wird das besser kontrolliert wird und
dann wird man beobachten müssen ob wir
die dynamik damit stoppen oder zumindest
reduzieren können bei der jetzigen
dynamik laufen wir in eine sehr sehr
schwierige situation rein insbesondere
für alle menschen die in krankenhäusern
und insbesondere in der intensiv medizin
arbeiten wir haben immer gesagt wir
wollen unser gesundheitssystem nicht
überfordern wir wissen dass wir das
heute nicht flächendeckend einhalten
können glücklicherweise haben wir noch
an einigen an vielen stellen kapazitäten
aber es ist wirklich
absolute zeit zum handeln und deshalb
war diese mbk heute notwendig und wir
werden permanent beobachten müssen ob
das was wir beschlossen haben reicht
oder ob wir doch zu einer noch
schwierigeren situation kommen was ich
nicht hoffe und es wird jetzt von jedem
auch abhängen sich an die dinge zu
halten ich kann dazu nur auffordern denn
wir sind in einer sehr ernsten situation
herr ministerpräsident wüst
vielen dank frau bundeskanzlerin meine
sehr verehrten damen und herren der
gesundheitsschutz hat unsere absolute
priorität und gemessen an dem ziel ist
die lage sehr ernst die stimme der
einschätzung der bundeskanzlerin
uneingeschränkt zu seit elf tagen
täglich ein neuer rekordwert an
neuinfektionen die inzidenz liegt in
deutschland bei über 330
tendenz steigend wir müssen uns klar
machen was diese entwicklung bedeutet
für gestern wurden welt 65.000
neuinfektionen von diesen menschen
werden ohne dass wir heute noch einen
einfluss darauf haben viele hundert
menschen
sterben und das gilt genauso für die tag
davor dafür und für den heutigen tag
wir sind in dieser pandemie sehr sehr
nahe an dem punkt an dem wir nie kommen
wollten dass in deutschen krankenhäusern
entschieden werden muss wenn man noch
behandeln kann und unser oberstes gebot
muss sein diesen notstand mit allen zur
verfügung stehenden mitteln zu
verhindern die gesundheit der
bürgerinnen und bürger hat absoluten
vorrang das ist das wichtigste das ist
aktuell das entscheidende und darum war
es so wichtig und so gut dass bund und
länder heute endlich zusammen gekommen
sind wir waren in der pandemie immer
dann am stärksten wenn man gemeinsam
agiert hat wenn man geschlossen agiert
hat gemeinsames geschlossenes vorgehen
schafft akzeptanz und vertrauen und
beides werden wir in den kommenden
wochen noch brauchen ich bin sehr froh
dass dieses verständnis dieser geist die
heutigen beratungen geprägt hat der
dreiklang heißt vorsicht
testen bund und länder sind deshalb
bereit zu einer fläche nden
flächendeckenden anwendung von 2g zweig
plus und weiteren maßnahmen wenn es die
hospitalisierung since it ends in drei
schritten 369 erfordert die länder sind
darüber hinaus bereit und entschlossen
zu einer massiven ausweitung der muster
impfung und alle länder halten eine
impfpflicht in heilberufen mit der
weiteren mitarbeitern krankenhäuser und
einrichtungen der eingliederungshilfe
für
erforderlich weil dort mit wohlhabenden
menschen umgegangen wird im einzelnen
wir setzen jetzt bundesweit ab eine
hospitalisierung rate von 3 und
freizeitbereich auf zweige regeln bei
einem wert von 6 auf 2 g + regeln und
bei einem wert von 9 in abstimmung mit
den landtagen so sieht es das
infektionsschutzgesetz dann ja vor auch
auf weitere maßnahmen auch am
arbeitsplatz brauchen wir mit der 3g
regel ein deutlich höheres schutzniveau
das gleiche gilt für den psv den
regional- und
fernverkehr für personen die nicht
geimpft werden können für personen für
die keine allgemeine impfempfehlung
vorliegt und für kinder und jugendliche
bis 18 gelten natürlich ausnahmen wir
sind einig dass der vollzug deutlich
gestärkt werden muss wir brauchen
strikte kontrollen von imd genesen und
fest nachweisen
um die vierte welle brechen zu können
brauchen wir jetzt erneut einen
nationalen kraftakt beim impfen wir
werden daher unsere im kapazitäten
massiv und flächendeckend ausbauen
nachdem wir in den pflege- und
altenheimen mit dem fußball angefangen
haben wollen wir nun allen menschen
frühestens nach dem fünften monat ein
angebot für eine auffrischungsimpfung
machen
zusätzlich zum regelsystem der hausärzte
werden alle länder ihre
impfmöglichkeiten massiv
wir waren uns auch einig dass wir
vor allen dingen mit diesem vorgehen die
verwundbarsten stärker schützen müssen
deswegen halten im übrigen auch alle
länder für erforderlich da gab es eine
große einigkeit dass wir einrichtungs
bezogen angehörige von heyl und
pflegeberufen mitarbeiter mit einer
krankenhäusern sowie einrichtungen der
eingliederungshilfe
pflichtig impfen lassen wollen also
erstmals eine impfpflicht
zum testen testen bedeutet zusätzliche
vorsicht und vorsorge für sich selbst
und für andere deshalb ist richtig dass
es die schnelltests wieder überall
kostenlos gibt insbesondere für menschen
mit kleinem geldbeutel eine wichtige
zusätzliche schutz optionen
auch durch tests müssen wir das
schutzniveau für die verwundbarsten
deutlich erhöhen gerade in alten- und
pflegeheim
pflegepersonal insbesondere auf den
intensivstationen leistet in diesen
tagen wieder
großartiges ihnen allen danke ich im
namen aller ministerpräsidentin
ministerpräsidenten und der menschen in
unserem land für ihren unermüdlichen
einsatz
wir wollen das mit blick auf die
besondere belastung des personals aber
nicht bei dankesworten belassen deswegen
erneut ein pflege bonus
dass parallel zu den heutigen beratung
hat der bundestag eine änderung des
infektionsschutzgesetzes beschlossen die
morgen im bundesrat beraten wir dazu
möchte ich für die b länder sagen dass
wir weiterhin einen ausreichenden
instrumentenkasten für erforderlich
halten es ist aus unserer
überzeugung es ist ja bekannt als
falsche signal die epidemische lage von
nationaler tragweite auslaufen zu lassen
ihre verlängerung wäre das beste und
rechts sicherste mittel gewesen aus
unserer sicht brauchen wir auch über den
fünfzehnter dezember hinaus die
notwendigen instrumente zur bekämpfung
von regionalen hotspots um die menschen
bestmöglich zu schützen es kann aus
sicht der ländern der länder gerade die
auch heute schon besonders hohen zu
zahlen haben nicht sein dass in extremen
hotspots die schließung von
gastronomischen betrieben in einer
region nicht blicken der flächendeckend
möglich ist wissenschaftliche
erkenntnisse zeigen dass gerade da die
meisten infektionen entstehen und zwar
wichtig dass wir heute eine zusage vom
bund erhalten dass der
instrumentenkasten das des
infektionsschutzgesetzes
spätestens mitte dezember evaluiert wird
diese zusage haben wir heute vom
bundesfinanzminister erhalten für den
fall dass einer von ihm angeführten
bundesregierung wird spätestens bei der
mpk am 19 dezember
bewertet ob die maßnahmen ausreichend
sind und es werden gegebenenfalls auch
kurzfristig änderungen vorgenommen für
mich und die unionsgeführten länder
steht fest als regierung eines landes
muss sich in jedem moment für den fall
eines falles voll handlungsfähig sein um
die menschen zu schützen deshalb ist
diese evaluierungs klausel visierte
vereinbart haben wichtig und ich danke
dafür ausdrücklich und das möchte ich
ganz herzlich danke schön sagen allen
bürgerinnen und bürgern die sich ihre
liebsten und andere haben durch eine
impfung schützen lassen alle bislang
ungeimpften bürgerinnen und bürger bitte
ich erneut sich solidarisch zu zeigen
und sich zügig impfen zu lassen nur so
werden wir die pandemie effektiv
bekämpfen vielen dank herr
regierender bürgermeister müller bitte
wir sind mitten in einer vierten welle
sie hat uns voll getroffen und die
auswirkungen sind dramatisch da gibt es
nichts drumherum zureden zu beginn der
woche war ich mit den beiden chefs der
landeseigenen kliniken in einer
pressekonferenz und sie haben in aller
klarheit geschildert wo wir stehen ja
und berichtet von verzweifelten
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeitern in der
charité und vivantes von den bitteren
momenten denn auch junge menschen
versterben die ungeimpft sind schwangere
dabei
sie haben berichtet was es für eine
physische und psychische belastung es
über wochen und monate
diese schwerst erkrankten auf den
intensivstationen zu sehen sie sind also
in einer dramatischen situation
aber das will ich hinzufügen auch nicht
weil nichts passiert ist es ist viel
passiert in den letzten monaten wir
haben mit vielen maßnahmen mit vielen
entschlossenen maßnahmen die wir
umgesetzt haben bund und länder auch
vielen menschen geholfen wir haben viele
leben auch gerettet
das ist aber auch klar dass wir fest
davon ausgegangen sind dass wir jetzt in
diesen tagen schon eine höhere impfquote
haben können erinnere immer wieder daran
wie wir doch so darauf gehofft haben ein
medikament oder eine impf möglichkeit zu
haben zu beginn der pandemie und wir
doch eigentlich im ernst alle
miteinander nicht damit gerechnet haben
dass es so schnell gehen können da ein
impfstoff zur verfügung zu haben wir
hatten ihnen dann schnell zur verfügung
wir haben ihn eingesetzt wir haben die
impfzentren aufgebaut impfstellen mobile
teams wir sind vor ort gewesen in kinos
shopping malls auf öffentlichen plätzen
und haben viele menschen impfen können
aber die imk not quote ist eindeutig zu
niedrig sind immer noch rund 25
millionen menschen in unserem land die
nicht geimpft sind selbst wenn man die
abzieht die sich noch nicht impfen
lassen können ist die impfquote immer
noch zu niedrig ist sie zu viele
menschen die die impf angebote nicht
annehmen obwohl sie es tun könnten
ich sag an der stelle auch bleibe dabei
meiner meinung es liegt nicht daran dass
es zu wenig aufklärung gegeben hat in
den letzten monaten zu wenig werben zu
wenig impfmöglichkeiten zu wenig
infrastruktur zu wenig geld zu wenig
impfstoffe oder zu wenig
entschlossenheit ist nicht der grund
sondern der grund ist dass es zu viel
egoismus und zu viel gleichgültigkeit
gibt das tatsächlich einige immer noch
der meinung sind in dieser
solidargemeinschaft kommt auf ihr
verhalten nicht an und doch es kommt auf
ihr verhalten an sich und andere zu
schützen ist lebens ist
überlebensnotwendig
das muss man so klar sagen
und insofern werden wir natürlich auch
weiter werben werden weiter angebote
machen alle bundesländer überall wir
haben wie es eben geschildert wurde
heute miteinander beschlossen die
angebote deutlich auszubauen die
impfzentren die impfstellen es wird
weiter die mobilen teams geben
selbstverständlich
wir werden weiter und personal haben um
noch schneller auch die
auffrischungsimpfung anbieten zu können
alles richtig aber genauso richtig ist
es jetzt auch deutlich zu machen dass es
nicht ewig so weitergehen kann dass eine
minderheit eine mehrheit dominiert und
deren gesundheit gefährdet und dass wir
jetzt auch entschlossen die 2g regeln
umsetzen oder auch zwei gpus es war
wichtig dass wir uns heute zwischen bund
und ländern auf diesen fahrplan wie er
beschrieben wurde verständigen konnten
mit den entsprechenden
grenzen die dann zu 2g zweig plus oder
doch darüber hinausgehende maßnahmen
führen glaube dass das nötig ist und
dass es viele menschen gibt die
inzwischen auch darauf warten dass sie
als genesen und geimpfte auch die
möglichkeit haben weiterdingen anspruch
nehmen zu können und das andere die sich
nicht impfen lassen eben auch damit
leben müssen dass sie nicht mehr so
uneingeschränkt zugang zu vielen
lebenssituationen haben oder andere
beschränkungen in kauf nehmen müssen
oder sich sind auch testen lassen müssen
oder andere maßnahmen hinnehmen müssen
ja meine damen und herren ich glaube
dass jenseits dieses hochfahren der
kapazitäten die wir uns vorgenommen
haben und die 2g regeln ist auch wichtig
ist dass wir noch mal klar gesagt haben
dass es strenge tests pflichten gibt in
den pflegeheimen in den medizinischen
einrichtungen natürlich auch um die
betroffenen die dort sind und die die
schutzlosesten sind dass wir sie so gut
es geht eben doch auch schützen können
mit diesen maßnahmen ich glaube das ist
ein wichtiges signal dass wir uns heute
darauf verständigt schleunigst für
bestimmte berufsgruppen einrichtungs
bezogene im pflichten im bauch in
angriff zu nehmen dass das
vorangetrieben werden muss und ich will
auch noch hinzufügen abschließend dass
ich darauf setzte dass wir natürlich den
maßnahmenkatalog den wir haben durch den
beschluss des deutschen bundestages auch
in den ländern entschlossen umsetzen und
wir haben einen weitgehenden
maßnahmenkatalog zur verfügung wir
hatten ihn in den letzten wochen zur
verfügung viele die beklagen dass manche
dinge nicht umgesetzt worden sind hätten
es tun können in eigener verantwortung
auch für die nächsten wochen ist das
noch möglich und gerade diese nächsten
wochen sind auch entscheidend für die
frage wie über dezember und januar kommt
dafür hat uns der bundestag mit seinen
beschlüssen die entsprechenden
möglichkeiten gegeben und insofern setze
ich auch darauf dass es jetzt jenseits
von möglicherweise
ansprüche die die eine seite an die
andere seite hat einfach dazu kommt dass
wir jetzt auch wirklich
konstruktiv mit dieser beschlusslage
umgehen ich will mich den dank den herr
wüst eben angesprochenen ausgesprochen
hat ausdrücklich anschließen den dank an
so viele wenn ich mich anschließen die
solidarisch in den letzten monaten waren
so viel mitgetragen haben so besonnen
verhalten haben und sich und andere
geschützt haben und ich will diesen dank
aber auch nochmal mit einem deutlichen
appell verbinden sich jetzt nicht
zurückzulehnen sondern dass alle noch
einmal mit helfen entweder jetzt wenn
sie es noch nicht getan haben angebote
annehmen die angebote annehmen zur
dritten impfung zu dieser
auffrischungsimpfung und ja jetzt in
dieser phase wo so viele angebot
hoffentlich auch annehmen kann es zu
wartezeiten kommen ich bitte dafür um
verständnis wir werden alles tun um so
schnell wie möglich auch dieser info
angebote besser und schneller umsetzen
zu können
aber bitte warten sie nicht einfach
darauf in den nächsten wochen sondern
bemühen sie sich jetzt um diese
auffrischungsimpfung bemühen sie sich um
termine jeder tag zählt
und ich möchte auch nach dem appell
formulieren dass wir jenseits von
kämpfen erster und zweiter und
auffrischungsimpfung auch weiter daran
denken uns an regeln zu halten es wird
wichtig bleiben auch mit einer impfung
wird es wichtig bleiben auf abstand
hygiene auf maske tragen auf all diese
regeln weiter zu achten um wie gesagt
nicht nur uns selbst sondern andere zu
schützen dann der herr minister scholz
unser land befindet sich in einer neuen
krone welle die paris infektion nehmen
mit großer geschwindigkeit zu wir merken
dass es eine wachsende belastung gibt
auf den intensivstationen und das ist
etwas was wir uns alle gerne erspart
hätte
klar ist dass viele sich jetzt sorgen
machen ängste neu entstehen auch
erinnerung wieder hochkommen an die
situation wie sie war im letzten winter
und in den anderen wählen die uns so
herausgefordert haben und deshalb ist es
ganz ganz wichtig dass wir uns jetzt
unterhaken das land gemeinsam handeln
und all die notwendigen maßnahmen
ergreifen und die schritte unternehmen
die wichtig sind um die gesundheit der
bürgerinnen und bürger zu schützen jeder
für sich aber auch wir uns alle
gemeinsam
deshalb ist es gut dass wir jetzt eine
reihe von maßnahmen unternehmen können
die mit den neuen gesetzgebung des
bundestages möglich geworden sind und es
ist sehr gut dass auch die
ministerpräsidenten konferenz zusammen
mit der bundesregierung jetzt konkrete
präzise beschlüsse gefasst hat über das
was jetzt zu tun ist damit wir gut durch
diesen winter kommen denn das ist genau
das was wichtig ist wir müssen jetzt die
monate die vor uns liegen wo die
infektion schon wegen der jahreszeit
wieder zunehmen werden als monate
betrachten in denen wir mit großer
geschwindigkeit die anstrengung auf den
weg bringen die wir jetzt brauchen dazu
zählt zuallererst dass sich diejenigen
impfen lassen die sich noch nicht haben
impfen lassen und mein appell ist dass
alle sich jetzt an ruck geben und die
entscheidung für sich selber für ihre
liebsten für ihre angehört treffen und
es ist gut dass wir deshalb eine solche
ausweitung der imf angebote bekommen in
den arztpraxen aber auch bei den
öffentlichen angeboten mit mobilen
impfmöglichkeiten mit impfmöglichkeiten
in den neu eröffneten impfzentren es ist
wichtig dass wir
viele davon überzeugen dass sie sich
jetzt an der auffrischungsimpfungen dann
auch das hilft durch die pandemie und es
ist klar da geht es um millionen denn
viele haben sich ja schon ein und
zweimal impfen lassen und alleine wenn
diejenigen sich noch impfen lassen ein
drittes mal die jetzt so knapp sechs
monate seit der letzten impfung zurück
haben dann wird das bis zum jahresende
fast nicht ganz 30 millionen
auffrischungsimpfung umfassen das zu
organisieren das möglich zu machen das
ist eine große anstrengung die alle
miteinander vor sich nehmen müssen
überall in den städten und gemeinden in
deutschland in den landkreisen in den
ländern und wir müssen das jetzt
organisieren dazu hat sich die
ministerpräsidentin und
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz verabredet
dazu ist die bundesregierung
entschlossen und dazu sind die
grundlagen mit den entscheidungen des
bundestages auch getroffen worden wir
werden um durch den winter zu kommen
einschneidende maßnahmen sehen die es
bisher nicht gegeben hat ich will das
noch mal anrufen wir werden an den
arbeitsplätzen die 3g regelung umsetzen
weil angesichts der tatsache dass so
viele sich haben impfen lassen und das
für alle die möglichkeit besteht sich
impfen zu lassen dass auch jetzt die
konkret mögliche und richtige maßnahme
zum schutz aller bürgerinnen und bürger
ist aber es ist ein schritt ein
weitreichender schritt das gleiche gilt
für die regelung die wir für den
öffentlichen verkehr getroffen haben und
der bundestag jetzt vorbereitet hat auch
das trägt zu größerer und mehr
sicherheit in unserem land
mein wunsch ist also dass wir alle das
jetzt als zeit nutzen in der wir zeigen
dass wir als land zusammenhalten können
das gilt für die bürgerinnen und bürger
und da darf man darauf setzen dass viele
das auch miteinander machen werden und
dass sie ihren beitrag leisten werden
aber das gilt auch für uns alle die wir
verantwortung haben im öffentlichen
leben dieses landes dass das möglich ist
davon bin ich nach dem heutigen tag sehr
überzeugt es werden gute beratung und
bundestagswahl eine gute beratung hier
in der ministerpräsidentenkonferenz zwar
eine gute beratung zwischen der
bundesregierung und den regierungschefin
und regierungschefs der länder und ich
glaube so müssen wir weitermachen
vielen dank die erste frage kommt von
herrn feld von der ard
christa die bericht aus berlin eine
frage zum thema kontrollen bei 2g und 3g
zunächst an sie frau bundeskanzlerin
wann sind sie denn persönlich das letzte
mal zum beispiel im restaurant nach
ihrem zertifikat gefragt worden und ganz
grundsätzlich gerne auch an den rest der
runde wie soll das gelingen das wirklich
überall das praktisch kontrolliert wird
dankeschön
also ich persönlich
bin sowieso nicht so viel unterwegs aber
nachts esstisch einigung bin ich schon
gefragt worden bei veranstaltungen die
das vorher angekündigt haben bei
restaurants zu denen ich mich hier raus
erzählung dass es einfach noch viel zu
wenig kontrolliert wird es wird kann nie
flächendeckend kontrolliert werden aber
es muss eine systematik entstehen bei
der jeder kreis dass die gefahr einer
kontrolle da ist und dieses ist noch
nicht überall flächendeckend der fall
gewesen aber ich glaube jetzt haben alle
ihre entschlossenheit irgendwo auch
deutlich gemacht das war auch bei den
ländern heute spürbar dass das gewollt
wird ich war gestern auch werden
deutsche stehen dann sag auch da ist
inzwischen eine große bereitschaft dafür
da bei jeder sieht was los ist in den
eigenen krankenhäusern und das muss
verändert werden dass ich das so weiter
entwickelt
seine frau dunst
warten sie auf das i
die explodierenden infektionszahlen
zeigen ja wie dramatisch die große
koalition und auch die länder im
bundestagswahljahr die kontrolle über
dieses virus verloren hat und die ampel
parteien herr scholz wirken jetzt ja
auch nicht gerade überzeugen frau
bundeskanzlerin wie schwer tragen sie an
diesem vertrauensverlust in der
bevölkerung und wenn sie heute ganz frei
ohne ministerpräsidenten und herrn
scholz hätten entscheiden können was
hätten sie verfügt und herr scholz sie
können im gegensatz zu frau merkel nun
lehren aus fehlern ziehen es wirkt ja
absurd bei diesen zahlen die pandemische
lage auslaufen zu lassen warum haben sie
es nicht verhindert ist das der preis
für eine regierung mit der fdp
also von meiner seite würde ich sagen
wir haben anfang august also bereits im
wahlkampf ja eine
mpk gehabt die einige maßnahmen
festgelegt hat insbesondere das 3g wir
haben damals keine mehrheit für zwei wie
gehabt das bedaure ich ich hätte das
damals schon als eine möglichkeit gerne
ins auge gefasst heute hat er die
entwicklung dazu beigetragen dass das
natürlich jetzt ganz normal erscheint
und ganz sinnvoll im august gab es
darüber noch lange diskussionen ob man
solche radikalen maßnahmen machen kann
und wir ich hätte auch gerne dieser mpk
etwas früher gehabt aber da will ich
jetzt nicht lange nachdenken der
instrumentenkasten ist bei den ländern
natürlich zur verfügung gewesen und die
frage wann man handelt ist vielleicht
immer noch ein bisschen davon getragen
dass die dramatik exponentiellen
wachstums über das sich oft gesprochen
hat habe manchmal unterschätzt wird
jetzt haben wir aber sozusagen uns hier
zusammengefunden und was ich mir
gewünscht hätte ist dass wenn schon die
epidemische lage von nationaler
tragweite abgeschafft werden muss was
mir überhaupt nicht einleuchtet was ihr
psychologisches signal auch immer für
falsch gehalten habe aber wenn das schon
sein muss dann hätte ich mir wenigstens
gewünscht dass die länder den gleichen
katalog zur verfügung haben wir bisher
im 28 da ist ausgenommen die
ausgangssperren sage ich ganz deutlich
und ausgenommen die frage der
flächendeckenden schulschließung beides
wollen wir nicht aber es gibt eine ganze
reihe von maßnahmen die jetzt nicht in
diesem infektionsschutzgesetz wie es
jetzt ist da sind wir brauchen uns nicht
über epidemische lager so da so
unterhalten jetzt können die länder dann
auch machen aber den maßnahmenkatalog
hätte ich mehr umfassender gewünscht
es ist gut dass wir hier zu gemeinsamen
ergebnissen gekommen sind und dadurch
werden jetzt entscheidungen auf den weg
gebracht die schnell zügig ergriffen
werden überall in deutschland darum geht
es ja das geschieht jetzt auch zu einem
zeitpunkt wo es darauf ankommt und es
wird nicht stück für stück geschehen
sondern gewissermaßen in einem großen
grund einer großen anstrengung die
überall in deutschland jetzt unternommen
wird das ist auch glaube ich ein ganz
großer vorzug vor früheren situationen
wo viele vielleicht gezögert haben
wurden unterschiedlichen stellen
deutschlands unterschiedliche maßnahmen
ergriffen worden sind jetzt sehe ich
schon das mal abgesehen von den
auswirkungen des der unterschiedlichen
lage beim infektionsgeschehen trotzdem
hier gemeinsam gehandelt wird ich würde
nur sagen zweig wird jetzt überall
gemacht dass es die konsequenz der
verabredung wir haben all die neuen
möglichkeiten die mit den sehr scharfen
regelungen der gesetzgeber geschaffen
hat verbunden sind und das wird auch
dazu beitragen dass wir besser durch
diese situation kommen also hier ist
jetzt die grundlage für gemeinsames
handeln und auch dafür dass alle ihrer
verantwortung gerecht werden und ich bin
auch überzeugt werden dass herr blank
dpa
frau bundeskanzlerin können sie uns
erklären und den sportfans hier gilt
zweig jetzt auch auf dem fußballplatz
für fußball profis soll unter punkt acht
heißt es das 2g auch gelte für
sportveranstaltungen und aus übungen
also es entsteht die frage ob jetzt
künftig sportprofis ungeimpft noch
fußball spielen dürfen und die frage an
herrn wüst sie haben sich dazu heute
nicht geäußert wie verhalten sie sich
denn morgen im bundesrat wird nordrhein
westfalen gegen das
infektionsschutzgesetz die ampel
vorschläge dazu stimmen und wie
verhalten sich die unionsgeführten
länder insgesamt danke
zu dem infektionsschutzgesetz muss ich
mal dieser stelle verweisen auf den
bundesfinanzminister der glaube ich
intensiver ist verhandelt hat also
normalerweise ist es so dass die
arbeitswelt
3gs
und
nicht dort zweig verhängt wird auch wenn
dem bundesland der schwellenwert 3000
italy sierung überschritten wird zwei
gilt dann sozusagen für alles was nicht
die arbeitswelt ist und jetzt kommt es
darauf an ob
das die arbeitswelt ist oder ob es
sozusagen wie freizeit will das so
verstehe ich darf aber ich bin
weder jurist dennoch ich mich mit dieser
spezifischen sache intensiv befasst
notfalls muss das nachrechnen also auf
alle fälle ist es so dass wir hier einen
so großen katalog haben von maßnahmen
die möglich sind ist das mal auf die
alle jetzt mit dem gesetz im einzelnen
beschrieben sind und es wird eine ganz
große veränderung mit sich bringt das
wird auch die nächsten tage ihre bricht
das dach musste erträgen wenn ich jetzt
noch vorher sagen weil natürlich
gegenwärtig erst mal um das ist völlig
in ordnung diskutiert worden ist was
geht denn was wird gemacht was kommt da
rein und das ist in einzelnen fragen im
mittelpunkt gewesen tatsächlich wird es
aber so sein dass hier ein sehr
umfassender und auch in vielen fällen
weiter reichende handlungskatalog zur
verfügung steht als der bisher zur
verfügung stand und gleichzeitig ist es
so dass hier auch noch die verabredung
mit verbundenes weite teile davon auch
jetzt schon aktiv umzusetzen
ansonsten hat die kanzlerin ist trotz
der einschränkungen wie sie vorgenommen
hat sehr präzise beschrieben es gibt
regelungen für freizeitveranstaltung da
sind beschränkungen möglich wenn sie vor
ort jeweils gegriffen werden dazu ist
aber auch nur ist auch zweig vorgesehen
für die teilnehmer und teilnehmer das
ist ja damit verbunden und
selbstverständlich bedeutet das auch
dass dann für die teil diejenigen die
hier berufstätig sind die regeln gelten
die für den arbeitsplatz gelten die
länder haben natürlich die möglichkeit
beides zusammen zu führen wenn sie das
zu einer einheitlichen veranstaltung
machen das ist aber eine entscheidung
die dann vor ort zu treffen ist
sie haben mich nicht infrage und will
trotzdem noch angehen habe in den
vorbesprechungen der länder chefinnen
und chefs waren wir uns sehr schnell
einig dass wenn zuschauer im stadion
zweig beachten müssen dass das nach
unserer auffassung auch für die profis
gelten soll und die rechtslage war klar
ob wir das umgesetzt gegen müssen wir
jetzt prüfen aber das war einhellige
auffassung der ministerpräsidentin und
ministerpräsidenten werde jetzt zum
nicht adressierten teil ihrer frage ich
werde jetzt im lichte der ergebnisse
dieses tages mit dem papier natürlich
die abstimmung in der nordrhein
westfälischen landesregierung
suchen und dann werden wir wie es in
viereinhalb jahren guter zusammenarbeit
immer gewesen ist in nordrhein westfalen
eine gemeinsame linie für morgen finden
sie haben ja jetzt die
ministerpräsidenten sich darauf
verständigt eine impfpflicht für
bestimmte berufsgruppen
einzuführen dem haben ja wenn alle
zugestimmt haben auch die
landesregierungen mit fdp beteiligung
zugestimmt herr scholz was bedeutet das
denn jetzt für die meinungsfindung
innerhalb ihre zukünftigen möglichen
zukünftigen koalition sie haben ja
jüngst auch gesagt dass sie das
eigentlich befürworten dass man in die
diskussion eingestiegen ist wie schnell
kommt diese impfpflicht jetzt die
mehrheit im bundesrat haben sie ja schon
mal
da die bundesregierung sich
einvernehmlich mit den ländern auf
diesen text verständigt kann man daraus
entnehmen dass diese aufgeschlossenheit
sehr weitreichend christ und auch in die
nächste regierung hinein reicht insofern
ist jetzt der prozess eröffnet für eine
gesetzgebung zu dem thema man sieht an
der tatsache dass wir die formulierung
im einzelnen fünf mal hin und her
gewendet haben die jetzt in dem
beschluss steht dass da auch noch
richtig gesetzgebungsarbeit und auch
öffentliche anhörung dazu notwendig sind
wie man das im 19 macht aber mit den
beschluss der hier getroffen worden es
mit der
entscheidung der koalition über der
künftigen koalition eine diskussion
darüber zu eröffnen ist natürlich auch
vorgegeben dass am ende dabei auch etwas
herauskommt und ich befürworte dass wie
ich ja schon gesagt habe ich halte das
auch für richtig und ich bin sehr froh
darüber dass wir jetzt eigentlich in
einer situation sind wo
gesellschaftliche konsens die auch
politik werden und zwar schnell und
zügig möglich sind die man sich vor
einem jahr und vor einem halben jahr
nicht hätte vorstellen können sich
greift noch mal an das thema 3g am
arbeitsplatz die frage von
entsprechenden regeln für den von den
regeln für den öffentlichen verkehr wo
wir gesagt haben auch da müssen
entsprechende vorschriften beachtet
werden und natürlich gilt das auch für
die frage der durchsetzung von in
voraussetzung für berufliche tätigkeiten
in bereichen wo menschen gefährdet sind
wenn sie von jemandem infiziert werden
können und genau das ist hier in
beschuss angelegt und ich befürworte
sehr dass das jetzt der fall ist und
meine haltung ist klar und die
geschäftsführerin die wollten wir sagen
die geschäftsstelle bundesregierung
weise der bundesgesundheitsminister wird
wie der hilfe leisten eingeläutet wird
das bei der gesetzgebung gehäusen wird
dann muss man also jetzt nicht 14 tage
gar nichts tun denn es bedeutet dass da
ist jetzt das startsignal gesetzt durch
die politischen debatten die vorher
stattgefunden haben und zu dem ich mich
verhalten haben und durch die
entscheidung heute ist glaube ich noch
mal ein richtiger schritt nach vorne
gemacht worden und mein eindruck ist es
findet eine sehr breite zustimmung
die dame in der letzten reihe
kontakt nina haase deutsche welle frau
bundeskanzlerin ich muss einfach diese
gelegenheit nutzen um ihnen eine frage
zur außenpolitik zu stellen wie
reagieren sie denn auf die
veröffentlichung des diplomatischen
brief
in den außenministern von deutschland
frankreich und russland durch die
russische seite hinsichtlich des
normandie formats die französische seite
hat sich schon geäußert und hat gesagt
das ist durchaus nicht
diplomatisch gang und gäbe dass
normandie format ist ihnen eine
herzensangelegenheit also ihre reaktion
würde uns
sachverhalt erklären ich habe mich den
ganzen brauch mit gesundheitspolitik
beschäftigt klar die russische seite hat
den diplomatischen briefwechsel zwischen
den außenministern heiko maas friedrich
und lavrov offentlich gemacht über
sputnik wirklich 25 seiten detailliert
eins zu eins die briefe und hella france
hat auch argumentiert dass er die
veröffentlichung nutzen möchte um die
position der russischen seite
darzustellen warum es zu keinem treffen
bisher gekommen ist
ja gut ich meine dass briefe
veröffentlicht sind ist ja nicht jetzt
so
überraschend als ich lese viele männer
brief in der zeitung
insofern hat man haben sicherlich keiner
etwas zu verbergen aber die tatsache
warum es zu keinem außenministertreffen
gekommen ist die wird mit sicherheit von
französischer und deutscher seite
einerseits und russischer seite
vollkommen unterschiedlich gesehen und
ich habe das immer in sehr bedauert ich
habe da auch den russischen präsidenten
darum gebeten dass gerade noch mit
solange ich auch bundeskanzlerin bin ein
solches treffen stattfindet ich hätte
mir sogar ein treffen auf chefebene
gewünscht das ist leider nicht zustande
gekommen und deshalb bedauere ich das
sehr und daran wird auch die
veröffentlichung des briefwechsels
nichts ändern das meiner meinung nach
ein solches treffen hätte stattfinden
können wenn wir dem man die heutige mpk
wenn wir sagen würden weil wir uns zehn
tage vorher noch nicht einig sind wie
was genau das ergebnis eines treffens
ist und deshalb treffen wir uns erst gar
nicht dann würden wir viel weniger
resultate ein solches treffen treffen
haben immer eine eigendynamik und
deshalb sind sie gut und wichtig und
deshalb bedauerlich ist dass es in
letzter zeit zu solchen treffen nicht
gekommen ist
da die letzte frage von herrn rinke
reuters
eine frage die an die kanzlerin und
vizekanzler geht als vertreter des
bundes sie haben jetzt für 2g und zweige
plus schwellenwerte festgelegt für die
länder warum sie nicht den größeren
schritt gegangen und haben bei der
zweijährige zum beispiel eine
bundesweite regelung verhängt denn
dieser grenzwert von 3 ist so niedrig
dass doch eigentlich jedes bundesland
ich glaube bis auf bremen im moment
diese regelung sowieso schon einführen
muss also warum nicht der große schritt
wie wir das ja auch früher hatten das
bundesweit jetzt zweig eingeführt wird
und dann entsprechend auch zweige plus
das ist doch eine bundesweit
verständigung wenn man die kriterien
festlegt an die darüber entscheidet wann
man den jeweils nächsten schritt geht
und in deutschland steht im grundgesetz
dass die länder die gesetze des bundes
in eigener verantwortung ausführen wir
sind ein förderer des land mit einer
hohen verwaltungskompetenz deshalb
treffen wir uns zum beispiel in solchen
veranstaltungen wie dem gemeinsamen
treffen der bundeskanzlerin mit den
ministerpräsidenten und
ministerpräsidenten der länder deshalb
gibt es die ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
den bundesrat und alle die verabredung
aber das ist doch jetzt sehr weitgehend
eigentlich macht ihre frage doch
insofern auch einen guten sinn zum
abschluss wir haben uns unter gehabt
deutschland handelt gemeinsam es gibt
klare kriterien wie wir entschieden
gegen die ausbreitung des corona virus
in deutschland weiter vorgehen wollen
wie wir die gesundheit der bürgerinnen
und bürger schützen worden viele
bürgerinnen und bürger machen sich große
sorgen sie wollen dass wir das gemeinsam
und gemeinsam anpacken und das ist jetzt
der schlusspunkt das ist etwas was wir
uns miteinander vorgenommen haben und
dazu gehören dann auch solche
weitreichenden strengen regeln wie wir
sie jetzt umsetzen ich glaube also dass
das heute ein guter tag war für den
zusammenhalt und deutschland ein guter
tag für eine aktive engagierte
bekämpfung der gesundheitsgefahren die
von dem corona virus ausgehen und es
sollte auch weiter so gehen wir müssen
das gemeinsam hinbekommen und wir werden
das auch gemeinsam hinbekommen uns in
dieser situation
auf einen weg zu begeben wie wir es
hinbekommt dass die gesundheit der
bürger bürger geschützt hat also ich
glaube das war wirklich ein guter tag
und ich will das auch noch mal sehr
persönlich sagen viele bürgern und
bürger sind besorgt sie machen sich
engst sie haben ängste sie wissen nicht
was da passieren wird und deshalb ist es
umso wichtiger dass wir entschlossen und
gemeinsam handeln das tut er in genau 1
ist auf die wenigen monate der bundes
notbremse war das ja immer unser eingang
uns mit dem ministerpräsidentin die
ministerpräsidenten auf bestimmte
schwellenwerte zu einigen insofern ist
das in einer langen tradition der
pandemie bekämpfung eine gute botschaft
meiner meinung nach
danke ich das beschluss dokument hat
herr brücher für sie
sind schriftlich und einen schönen abend
noch dankeschön
so jetzt haben wir sie gehört die
pressekonferenz tatsächlich auch mit
einigen neuigkeiten zum einen kommen
also den hospitalisierung index den die
kanzlerin angekündigt hat der soll nun
also der neue maßstab werden nicht mehr
die instanz sondern es ist der
hospitalisierung index der nun eine
große rolle spielen wird wie wir also
hier gemeinsam leben und zwar was ist
das der hospitalisierung index ist die
krankenhausaufnahme von corona patienten
pro 100000 einwohner im sieben tage
zeitraum was heißt dass das heißt also
dass das jetzt dann noch enger an die
belastungen des gesundheitssystems
geknüpft wird und wie hat sie das
gegliedert oder wie haben die
ministerpräsidenten und minister
präsidentinnen und kanzlerin merkel das
also sich überlegt dass soll wie folgt
sein also ab einem schwellenwert von 3
gilt nur noch 2 g bei einem
schwellenwert von 62 gibt plus und über
9 soll es noch zusätzlich kontakt
beschränkungen einschränkungen geben das
war aber noch nicht alles und es gibt
noch so viel mehr zu besprechen und
dafür ist nicole diekmann wieder bei uns
unsere hauptstadtstudio korrespondentin
nicole fangen wir vielleicht an aber
zunächst mit diesem neuen instrument du
hast es im vorfeld auch schon
angekündigt dass das kommen könnte du
hast es geahnt also vielleicht da deine
einschätzung wer hat sich da jetzt ist
es eine gemeinsame entscheidung gewesen
waren da jetzt alle dafür dass das so
kommen soll auch in dieser in dieser art
in dieser abstufung dass es zumindest
das was angela merkel gestern ja schon
angemahnt hat quasi angesprochen in
einem völlig anderen zusammenhang da war
sie beim städte- und gemeindetag
zugeschaltet hat eine rede gehalten und
eben den hospitalisierung index
schwellenwerte als eine aufgabe für
heute definiert dass man eben solche
schwellenwerte und daraus folgende
konsequenzen festlegt da hat man sich
anscheinend relativ schnell darauf
geeinigt denn das papier die
beschlussvorlage die wir heute hier
bekommen konnten im zdf hauptstadtstudio
die beinhaltete eben unter anderem schon
den wert 6 und auch den wert 9 das sind
ja das ist gerade gesagt das schadet ja
nicht erst noch mal zu wiederholen
das sind jetzt die werte 369 an denen
sich politik in den ländern orientiert
und kanzlerin merkel sagte aber auch sie
hätte sich einen umfassenden
maßnahmenkatalog ganz grundsätzlich
gewünscht wurde sie da jetzt über stimmt
und wenn ja von wem das war eine
mischung gerade diese
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
beziehungsweise diese pressekonferenz
die noch mal gezeigt hat in was für
einer schwierigen und in anbetracht
einer epidemie wirklich blöden sehr sehr
unglücklichen und sehr ungünstigen lage
deutschland ist es ist nie gut eine
pandemie ja das ist es ja zu haben aber
in einem wahljahr bzw in der zeit nach
einer wahl ist es wie wir sehen noch
schlimmer denn heute war ja nicht nur
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz heute war
ja auch das gesetzespaket der höchst
wahrscheinlich demnächst regierenden
ampel im bundestag in zweiter und
dritter lesung und dieses
infektionsschutzgesetz
bedeutet das ende der nationalen lage
epidemische tragweite nein der
epidemischen lage nationaler tragweite
so rum ist es richtig die ampel parteien
spd fdp und grüne wollen die beenden
deswegen nun dieses gesetzespaket das
das infektionsschutzgesetz wiederum
ändert und es wird allerhöchste
eisenbahn kommende dort kommenden
donnerstag läuft diese lage nämlich aus
die cdu und auch die csu sind strikt
dagegen
diese lage zu beenden die epidemische
lage nationaler tragweite wobei das muss
man auch dazusagen der noch
geschäftsführende cdu
bundesgesundheitsminister jens spahn als
erster die beendigung in den in die
diskussion eingebracht hat aber gut das
muss man einmal erwähnen das argument
dass unter anderem angela merkel eben
gebracht hat dagegen ist der
psychologische effekt man könne nicht
mitten in der vierten welle die hoch
dramatisch ist das sagte sie eben
quasi suggerieren es sei alles nicht so
schlimm und das hat sich eben heute um
zu der zum beginn meiner antwort
zukommen gezeigt in dieser
pressekonferenz da ist zum einen das
lager cdu vertreten gerade in der
pressekonferenz durch angela merkel und
den nordrhein westfälischen
ministerpräsidenten hendrik wüst und auf
der anderen seite unter anderem die spd
die in person von olaf scholz noch
bundesfinanzminister demnächst
höchstwahrscheinlich bundeskanzler und
dem regierenden bürgermeister von berlin
michael müller vertreten war und man hat
gemerkt auch wenn olaf scholz jetzt zum
schluss dieser pressekonferenz noch mal
sagte wir haben uns unter gehalt
deutschland handelt gemeinsam ich hab es
mir extra aufgeschrieben dieses gerangel
dieser streit um dieses gesetzespaket
das heute im bundestag war und morgen in
den bundesrat schon soll wie gesagt ist
das wurde sehr deutlich und darauf bezog
sich jetzt angela merkel dass sie sagt
ich habe erstens schon im august darauf
hingewiesen dass zweig kommen sollte da
habe ich mich nicht durchsetzen können
und ich halte auch dieses
instrumentarium das gesund das
gesetzespaket der ampel koalitionäre in
spe beinhaltet für nicht ausreichend
denn
das ist die argumentation der
unionsgeführten beziehungsweise der
unionsparteien das instrumentarium
reicht womöglich nicht in anbetracht der
ich wiederhole noch mal ich zitiere
dramatischen lage weil unter anderem
flächendeckende blog downs
ausgeschlossen werden nehmen wir noch
mal einen schritt weiter da war viel
drin also wir haben viel gehört eben
gerade in der pressekonferenz
beispielsweise sagte der regierende
bürgermeister von berlin müller es kann
nicht so weitergehen dass eine
minderheit eine mehrheit dominiert damit
meinte er menschen die nicht geimpft
sind
gleichzeitig war es aber insbesondere
auch die booster impfung auf die man da
jetzt ein augenmerk gelegt hat also
indem man mehr wieder das impfen
hochfährt und dann auch allen das war
das was was bei rausgekommen ist ein
impfangebot machen möchte führt auch die
auffrischungsimpfung ab 18 für die es ja
auch die stiko empfehlung gibt hat man
sich also ja auch die geimpften wieder
ins visier genommen aber was wird denn
im beispielsweise jetzt auch für
ungeimpfte menschen getan wurde darüber
auch gesprochen also wie man die
vielleicht noch mehr quasi animieren
könnte sich impfen zu lassen ja obwohl
auch dass das war der satz der der dem
von dir eben zitierten von müller
voranging gesagt müller behauptet
es habe nicht an mangelnder information
und aufklärung gelegen das läge nicht
daran dass so viele menschen geimpft
sein sondern ich habe mir das auch
aufgeschrieben das war schon sehr
beachtlich in der wird in der er das
gesagt hat
das läge an zu viel egoismus und
gleichgültigkeit damit war er also mit
abstand der schärfste in dieser vierer
runde gerade was aber auch betont wurde
und darauf zielt du ja ist die
wiedereinführung der kostenlosen bürger
tests die wurden ja abgeschafft vor
einigen monaten natürlich mit der
hoffnung dahinter damit den impf druck
auf die leute zu erhöhen denn wo keine
tests da keine ergebnisse und da im
zweifel eben auch kein einlass aber auch
das wurde eben thematisiert auch von
angela merkel bestätigt die kontrollen
dort wo drei gilt also entweder getestet
genesen oder geimpft die kontrollen
lassen doch sehr zu wünschen übrig das
heißt leute testen sich einfach nicht
mehr was aber nicht bedeutet dass sie
sich dann im verlassen sondern im
zweifel haben sie dann corona und es
geht aber in keiner statistik ein sie
wissen ist im zweifel selber nicht und
stecken andere art also die kostenlosen
bürger tests da war man eben sehr
zufrieden mit sich dass konnte man
heraushören die werden jetzt wieder
eingeführt was ist auch geben soll dass
es neue es eine impfpflicht für viel
also nicht nur für pflegeberufe also für
beschäftigte in krankenhäusern und eben
auch in pflegenden einrichtungen und war
das jetzt etwas wo alle sich einig waren
hersteller geschlossenheit war das also
wirklich eine entscheidung die von allen
kam tatsächlich da habe ich
daneben gelegen eben in der langen
strecke die wir miteinander gesprochen
haben vor dieser pressekonferenz die
sich ja doch noch mal um fast eine
stunde nach hinten verzögert hat ich war
davon ausgegangen wir hier waren davon
ausgegangen dass diese impfpflicht ein
zentraler streitpunkt heute sein könnte
wir haben das ja vergangenes wochenende
anfang dieser woche auch schon bei den
ampel parteien erlebt da jesus erst er
wir haben uns darauf geeinigt und dann
hieß es wiederum nein haben wir doch
nicht hendrik wüst
nordrhein-westfälischer
ministerpräsident nachfolger von armin
laschet hat es als erster eben gesagt
und betont alle länder wollen die
impfpflicht und angela merkel sagte nun
würde der bund sich dazu verhalten also
da gab es große einigkeit dass die jetzt
kommen müsse ja darüber sprechen wir
gleich auch noch mal mit unserem experte
für rechts- und justiz hier im studio
mit felix zimmermann an dich aber noch
zum schluss die frage welches signal
wollen denn jetzt hier die
ministerpräsidenten ministerpräsidentin
vielleicht auch damit setzen was war da
besonders wichtig du meinst jetzt mit
dieser pressekonferenz oder speziell mit
der
grundsätzlich mit den entscheidungen die
sie heute getroffen haben
zum einen dass man erkannt hat dass man
weiß wie dramatisch die lage ist denn da
gab es doch erhebliche fragezeichen von
vielen stellen in den vergangenen tagen
auch diese ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
auch da hat man das parteien gerade
wieder gesehen da sagte angela merkel
die habe sie sich schon früher gewünscht
die spd-regierten länder waren da eher
zögerlich also einmal den ernst der lage
haben wir erkannt dass war signal nummer
eins das man heute senden wollte und
zweitens das was ja immer enorm wichtig
ist in der politik handlungsfähigkeit
und entschlusskraft als drittes würde
ich nennen und als viertes einigkeit
aber wie gesagt das hat auch nur so
halbwegs gut funktioniert vielen dank
nicole diekmann dass du vorher so viel
zeit für uns hat es jetzt nochmal für
uns bereit war es danke für heute abend
sehr gerne und ich hab es schon
angesprochen wir können jetzt noch mal
ganz eingehend über die neue impfpflicht
für menschen in krankenhäusern und
pflegen fliegenden einrichtungen
sprechen mit felix zimmermann hier im
studio experte für recht und justiz
felix da gibt es fragen uns vielleicht
aber erstmal möchte ich auch kurz
einsatz noch vorlesen aus dem papier und
da steht nämlich diesbezüglich erst mal
die länder bitten den bund dies
schnellstmöglich umzusetzen also das
gilt ja jetzt noch nicht ab jetzt direkt
wie lange kann denn so was überhaupt
dauern bis so was dann auch wirklich
beschlossen ist ja oder ja auch gerade
urlaubszeit gerade angesprochen das ist
eine sache die liegt in der kompetenz
des bundes also da muss es einen
gesetzgebungsverfahren geben dann
theoretisch eine verordnung und da will
man jetzt das nicht einfach so lapidar
beschließen sondern muss natürlich auch
anhörungen stattfinden ist ja ein doch
gravierender grundrechtseingriff der da
stattfindet der legitim sein kann
insbesondere wenn man sich anschaut dass
eben die krankenhaus zahlen fallzahlen
ja eben immer mehr durch die decke gehen
ist eben diese impfpflicht für bestimmte
berufsgruppen die mit variablen personen
kontakt haben durchaus etwas was
verhältnismäßig sein kann überhaupt ist
er das positive würde ich jetzt mal aus
rechtlicher sicht sagen an diesen
beschlüssen dass man jetzt nun endlich
zwar immer lange die forderung von
diesen instanzen jedoch sehr wenig
aussagekraft haben in sonder weil ja
sehr pauschal immer gehalten sind
weggegangen ist und wirklich schaut wo
ist die lage dramatisch und das in einem
gestuften system nachdem dieser
hospitalisierung tendenz einfach
gesprochen nach dem ausmaß der belegung
von intensivstationen mit komapatienten
das zu stufen und immer strengere
maßnahmen machen die belastete das
system ist das ist auf jeden fall unser
freiheitlichen aspekten gute sache weil
dann wirklich der grundrechtseingriff
auch immer eine klare
rechtfertigung hat eben mit der
belastung des gesundheitssystems
ja und da ist die impfpflicht jetzt eben
möglicherweise mit dazu ich hab's ja
vorhin schon mal angedeutet es kann
nicht sein dass man wirklich massive
freiheitsbeschränkungen für in ordnung
hält ausgangs verschränkung kontakt
verboten
schließung von ganzen betrieben und dann
auf der anderen seite quasi als heilige
kuh hat auf keinen fall dass eine
impfpflicht geben das ist nicht in
einklang zu bringen mit den massiven
schäden die quasi mit 19 gesundheitlich
anrichtet und auch die einer ausgangs
beschränkung oder ein lockdown anrichtet
für kinder depression häusliche gewalt
und so weiter und so weiter das sind
massive dinge auf der einen seite und da
kann man nicht sagen aber es darf auf
keinen fall eine impfpflicht geben
gerade und da ist es jetzt auch noch mal
gestuft ist es jetzt aktuell nur in der
debatte im für bestimmte berufsgruppen
und das ist durchaus und der abwägung
wenn die lage ebenso dramatisch ist
verhältnismäßig in meinen augen und da
muss aber jetzt eben der bund das ganze
beschließen und wie hängt das jetzt
vielleicht auch zusammen das was wir
heute gehört haben also auf der bund
länder konferenz mit jetzt auch den
änderungen des infektionsschutzgesetzes
also wie ist daher auch deine ja jetzt
eine einordnung wie geht das jetzt
beides miteinander auch zusammen genau
das ist ein bisschen verwirrend auch nur
irgendwas in siders parlament und da
sind die ministerpräsidenten die autos
entscheiden ist aber eigentlich aber zu
erklären das parlament hat er den rahmen
bestimmt und hat dem ländern gewisse
sachen ermöglicht und länder haben eben
heute beschlossen okay das machen wir
auch und noch ein bisschen mehr neben
beispiel 3g kontrollen in bahn wird
gemacht 3g am arbeitsplatz wird
umgesetzt home office ist glaube ich
sowieso eine vorgabe als letztlich setzt
man oder hat man jetzt beschlossen das
was jetzt im neuen gesetz als als
instrument besteht auch zu machen
außerdem kostenlose tests und zudem eben
jetzt das neue die impfpflicht für
bestimmte berufsgruppen auf den weg zu
bringen steht hier im text an wir bitten
den bund ab wir haben von olaf scholz
gehört der bund ist einverstanden also
das wird jetzt wahrscheinlich relativ
zügig vonstatten gehen aber natürlich
muss man auch jedes rechtsverfahren
einhalten und muss anhörung machen weil
wie gesagt ein doch erheblicher eingriff
in grundrechte
nämlich dass die körperliche
unversehrtheit von personen die sich
impfen lassen müssen natürlich
eingeschränkt ist aber jede grundrechts
einschränkung hat eben die möglichkeit
einer rechtfertigung jedenfalls die
meisten und hier stehen ihnen auf der
anderen seite erhebliche schutzgüter
güter die für eine impfpflicht auch
sprechen in der abwägung vielen dank
felix zimmermann für die einordnung und
damit dass jetzt auch noch mal ganz klar
und sortiert das ist das ja gut wenn man
das auch noch mal schwarz auf weiß sieht
wir haben einen beitrag vorbereitet zu
allem was da jetzt drin steckte was
jetzt neu ist und was anders wird in
zukunft
der zugang zur gastronomie kultur und
sportveranstaltungen soll beschränkt
werden übersteigt in einem bundesland
die hospitalisierung rate also die quote
der klinikeinweisungen den wert 3 soll
flächendeckend 2 gelten ab einem
schwellenwert von 6 soll die 2g plus
regel zum einsatz kommen also geimpft
oder genesen + test ab schwellenwert 9
gibt es weitere einschränkungen etwa
kontakt beschränkungen am arbeitsplatz
kommt 3g zur anwendung auch im
öffentlichen personennahverkehr soll 3g
gelten
für personal in krankenhäusern und im
pflegebereich wollen die länder eine
impfpflicht und besonders verletzliche
gruppen zu schützen
beim impfen der gesamtbevölkerung
braucht es so wörtlich eine nationale
kraftanstrengung
ungeimpfte werden aufgefordert sich
solidarisch zu zeigen und sich schnell
impfen zu lassen damit alle schnell zum
zuge kommen sollen die angebote
ausgeweitet werden
das war ein beitrag von julia schröter
und jetzt ist auch mir wieder frau
professor falk zugeschaltet schön dass
sie auch noch bei uns in vielen dank
selbst auch gehört was für änderungen da
also in kraft treten sollen ganz
essenziell wird ja jetzt auch
beispielsweise die inzidenz ausgetauscht
gegen einen anderen wert also die
hospitalisierung rate damit wird das
ganze also enger ein bisschen enger auch
an das aktuelle gesundheitssystem
geknüpft wie wichtig war dass wir wie
wichtig finden sie diese maßnahme
diese maßnahme ist auf jeden fall
wichtig weil es wurde ja schon gesagt
die
fallzahlen sind manchmal ja auch sehr
schwer nachzuvollziehen gerade weil sie
regional sehr unterschiedlich sind und
ich glaube das signal war generell dass
ihr einheitliche rahmenbedingungen in
deutschland brauchen so habe ich das
signal wahrgenommen und es ist doch
tatsächlich so ich kenne die
niedersächsischer seite sehr gut in der
wir über die korona verordnung
informiert werden und den niedersachsen
ist das schon so da haben sie
verschiedene auflistungen und in der
niedersächsischen auf der
niedersächsischen seite ist schon in den
letzten wochen die hospitalisierung 's
rate angegeben und wenn man da drauf
geht dann waren die warnstufen andere
und die werden jetzt vereinheitlicht und
das ist jetzt natürlich eingangs
sinnvoller schritt dass man auch als
bürgerinnen und bürger sich informieren
kann wie sieht die hospitalisierung rate
aus in den jeweiligen bundesländern das
wird man vielleicht noch regional auch
noch aufschlüsseln können und dann kann
man sehen dass niedersachsen diese drei
jahr zwischen die sie erst den ersten
schritt zwischen drei und sechs
hospitalisierungen pro woche pro 100000
einwohner schon überschritten hat das
ist im moment 4,7 und da kann man glaube
ich sehr transparent dann auch
nachvollziehen wann welche maßnahmen
gelten ich denke das ist ein sehr
sinnvolles eine sehr sinnvolle maßnahme
das so auf den weg zu bringen
ich wollte dass euch auch jetzt hier
eigentlich gerade gerne zeigen auf
meinem bildschirm das können wir auch
mal versuchen nämlich diese das ist
nicht so einfach das rutsch mir die
ganze zeit weg gibt mir in kurzen moment
dass ich das hier für euch gut
einrichten kann also hier oben sehen wir
nach wie vor beim rk ii die sieben tage
incidents damit aber gehört dass das ja
jetzt nicht mehr von von viel wert ist
wenn es darum geht neue regeln zu
beschließen und jetzt suche ich mich
hier durch und dann habe ich gefunden
also hier ist die sieben tage incidents
nach hospitalisierung jetzt muss man nur
aber auch sagen also aktuell stand jetzt
noch wenn man da auf der seite unterwegs
ist ist das also der zeitraum für einen
monat den ich mir hier angucken kann und
aufgeschlüsselt nach einzelnen
bundesländern sich das jetzt auch nicht
also das ist vielleicht auch was das ist
jetzt noch nicht ad hoc so ganz klar
ersichtlich oder frau falk frau
professor falk wie dass ich genau
feststellen lässt vielleicht für jede
region oder ja ich hab das schon mal ein
bisschen gerade nebenbei versucht
herauszufinden für verschiedene
bundesländer also niedersachsen hat es
tatsächlich und da sieht man schon die
letzten wochen wie sich dieser wert
leider langsam nach oben bewegt hat
andere bundesländer haben einfach andere
darstellungsformen ich glaube die sind
einfach die länder wirklich jetzt
gefordert auf ihren webseiten wo sie die
korona verordnungen haben das dann genau
transparent und leicht verständlich auf
zufügen aufzuführen diese seite in
niedersachsen ist ja gut ich kenne ich
schon lange guckt da immer wieder drauf
und da sieht man es wirklich und kann
dann auch sehen wir kommen an diese
grenzwerte heran und es gibt die zahlen
die müssen jetzt nur von den ländern
entsprechend aufbereitet werden und dann
auch so auf den webseiten kommuniziert
werden und das lka hat ja die aufgabe
bundesweit zusammenzufassen und es gibt
werte die sind dann nach zum teil nicht
nur bundesländern sondern sogar
landkreisen aufgeschlüsselt da hatten
wir bis jetzt eben die fallzahlen das
gibt es immer eine excel-tabelle die
wird mit sicherheit jetzt ergänzt durch
diese excel-tabelle die nach landkreisen
oder zumindest bundesländern diese
hospitalisierung instanzen hat das ist
natürlich schon wichtig weil man daran
einfach sieht dass wir an einen punkt
gekommen sind wo unsere krankenhaus
kapazitäten wirklich extrem belastet
sind und ein punkt er ist grade so ein
bisschen untergegangen der ist mir total
wichtig es war nämlich auch die
bundeskanzlerin hat es gesagt dass es
eine einen bonus für die pflege gerade
auch die intensivpflege geben soll ich
glaube es ist ein ganz wichtiges signal
denn diese menschen leisten so viel seit
fast zwei jahren und es war mehr als
notwendig und jetzt wäre es gut wenn es
nicht nur bei worten gebe sondern auch
taten folgen und zwar schnell
gleichzeitig hatten im vorfeld auch
immer wieder hat noch immer wieder
berufsverbände davor gewarnt dass aber
auch zu machen also die impfpflicht in
jetzt krankenhäusern und für
pflegeberufe weil es da schon auch
befürchtungen gab dass das natürlich
noch mehr menschen abschrecken könnte in
diesem beruf zu arbeiten
da sind wir jetzt gar nicht was passiert
ich habe gerade von dem bonus gesprochen
ja genau das natürlich und absolut
selten ganz wichtig hier an diese
pflicht da hat herr müller einmal kurz
das noch mal diesen wichtigen begriff
erwähnt einrichtungs bezogen denn wie
sie richtig sagen es wäre auch kein
gutes signal jetzt ausgerechnet wieder
die pflegekräfte sozusagen da ein
besonders in die pflicht zu nehmen die
sowieso schon sehr viel leisten in den
krankenhäusern ist es sowieso schon so
dass da ein sehr hoher anteil der
pflegekräfte wirklich geimpft ist und
die muss man da wirklich auch mal in
schutz nehmen das sind nicht die
menschen geht er jetzt noch irgendwie
zur disposition stehen sondern die
einrichtungs bezogene impfpflicht die
diskutiert wird ist ja etwas das eben
nicht nur das direkte personal in der
pflege sondern wirklich auch vor allem
die mobilen alten und
pflegeeinrichtungen in mitte dahin
einnimmt und eben nicht berufsbezogen
ist so hab ich zumindest verstanden das
würde man auch nach allem was die
medizinerinnen und mediziner sagen er
einrichtungs bezogen machen wie es noch
ganz wichtig die umsetzung das hat herr
zimmermann ja gerade gesagt ist
natürlich an gesetzes vorgang derzeit
braucht was wir jetzt aber brauchen ist
handeln da ist ja eine möglichkeit die
auskunftspflicht zu ermöglichen so dass
arbeitgeber wissen wer es geimpft und
wer nicht so dass man ohne dass man
jetzt gesetzes dinge zur hand hat den
arbeitsalltag vielleicht so strukturiert
dass man für die variablen gruppen die
das risiko dass da menschen sind die
nicht geimpft sind einfach reduziert
indem man den arbeitsalltag etwas
umstrukturiert das wäre glaube ich eine
pragmatische herangehensweise ohne dass
man nämlich jetzt wartet bis diese
gesetzes geschichten da auf den weg
gebracht sind und das signal ist glaube
ich auch ganz wichtig dass das kommt
bewirkt ja auch schon einen handeln bei
den menschen das haben wir aus der cosmo
studie von cornelia betsch aus erfurt
gelernt die er immer sehr gut verfolgt
wie reagieren menschen auch die
situation und die hat eindeutig gezeigt
dass ankündigungen auch schon einen
moment um generieren so dass menschen
sich danach richten und danach handeln
und ich glaube das war heute ein sehr
gutes signal in die richtung in
drei wochen am 19 dezember soll wieder
evaluiert werden wir wo stehen wir dann
wohl wie geht es dann weiter frau
professor falk wenn in drei wochen erst
evaluiert wird und geschaut wird was hat
es gebracht sie haben es angesprochen
zeit haben wir eigentlich wenig also wo
stehen wir in drei wochen
das hing davon ab wie die menschen die
sich heute mit den nachrichten
beschäftigen darauf reagieren und
ein geborener optimist würde ich immer
das mitnehmen was eben aus der cosmo
studie heraus kommt diese ankündigungen
die sind die werden schon von den
menschen wahrgenommen ob das jetzt
regelungen sind die den arbeitsplatz
betreffen ob das regelungen sind wie man
sich mit 2g und 3g noch wo wo kann man
hingehen wie wird das organisiert es
werden kontrollen angekündigt allein das
ist glaube ich ein signal in die breite
der bevölkerung dass die situation nicht
nur ernst ist sondern dass sie auch ein
handeln erfordert und ich denke dass
oder meine hoffnung ist dass die
menschen begreifen dass sie auch schon
handeln können nämlich sich selbst
testen sich zu überlegen dass man
möglichst die impf angebote wahrnimmt
dass man die booster angebote wahrnimmt
die dritte impfung dass das handeln
jetzt schon einsetzt
vorausschauend weil man merkt wir sind
jetzt gefordert die politik braucht
immer zeit so dass das handeln jetzt
schon einsetzt und dass wir dann doch
etwas erreichen bis zu dieser nächsten
evaluation im neunten dezember so lange
ist es ja nicht mehr hin aber das wäre
ein bisschen die hoffnung dass die
menschen wirklich gemerkt habe um jeder
hat kann etwas dazu beitragen wirklich
jeder und jede und dass man das dann
auch wirklich versucht zu vermitteln
dass man handeln kann bevor der
gesetzgeber irgend etwas vorgibt und ich
glaube das signal kamen und zumindest
habe ich das so wahrgenommen schon auch
heute rüber sagt professor christine
folgt die präsidentin der deutschen
gesellschaft für immunologie vielen dank
für falsch dass sie für uns vorher und
nach dieser sendung bereitgestanden
haben und eingeordnet haben sehr gerne
und danke auch an alle die so lange uns
zugeschaut haben und dabei geblieben
sind und auch am anfang so viele fragen
gestellt haben ich hoffe ich konnte so
viele davon wie möglich von unseren
expertinnen und experten beantworten
lassen und vielen dank dass ihr dabei
waren bis dahin tschüss